so this new batch of Epstein documents
get released in it there is witness
statements about videos existing of Bill
Clinton Richard Branson and prince
Andrew abusing abusing Epstein's victims
there's also allegations that Donald
Trump was involved now many news outlets
reported this definitively as new
Epstein docs witness sayx however it has
now come out that these are old
allegations which is rather unsurprising
because we do know that many of these
documents had already been previously
released and apparently the witness has
recanted now there's a lot of people who
are very defensive of trump and they're
saying see these are these are these are
desperate allegations from someone
trying to bring attention to Epstein
they're not real she recanted but I got
to say there's still questions to be had
about the woman retracting these claims
considering what she followed up with by
saying that her family was in danger so
look Fair Point witness claims something
then says nothing there's not a lot to
go on what do you do the word is
basically meaningless but at the same
time considering Epstein and John Luke
brell kind of just you know um were
shuffled loose the Mortal coil from
their prison cells I wouldn't be
surprised to hear a witness recanting so
it is what it is but we'll talk about
this and much more Mexico wants Joe
Biden to give amnesty to 10 million
illegal immigrants in exchange for
assisting things are getting crazy we've
got some lighter news I don't I don't
know if they will develop into anything
serious but a car crash into the White
House Gates may just be a car crash May
be nothing serious but we do have some
of these stories to go through which we
will and we'll talk about uh JP Morgans
one of their top strategists said Joe
Biden will drop out in March over health
issues I think it makes sense you know
why here's the game plan we said I said
several times Joe Biden's going to drop
out then people said no Tim it's too
late they can't have a primary anymore
exactly Joe Biden stays in the race long
enough so that they can't hold primaries
cuz the deadline is passed then drops
out giving the DNC the ability to
appoint the successor without the
Democratic process avoiding another
Bernie Sanders situation and there you
have it we'll get into all that before
we get started my friends click the link
in the description below go to C
brew.com and low you will see Alex
Stein's Prime Time grind two times
caffeine coffee available now at Cas
brew.com uh you want to buy it because
buying from cbw helps support the show
and this particular Brew will actually
help support cat Charities for which we
have yet to choose but Alex Stein made
the request that the proceeds from this
will go to a nonprofit that helps sick
cats or otherwise homeless cats or just
cats in general and uh we will do such
we will do just that so go to cw.com buy
this also go to
timcast.net do a towns Town Hall style
event podcast hybrid with v ramaswami
Candace Owens will be joining us as well
very excited for this and um I'm just
going to I I got a request for a bunch
of press to attend including local news
outlets as well as CNN I'm really going
to enjoy CNN being in the audience not
that they'll be honest but I'm looking
forward to pointing out what the
definition of inside job is because you
can Google it so click join us become a
member cuz I got to tell you these
events they're very very expensive to
pull off but that's what we do when you
become a member that's what your funding
does you become a member 10 bucks we're
going to go do a bunch of stuff we've
got plans for a bunch of these primaries
we've got a big form planned in March
hopefully this all gets we we can do all
of this uh without a hitch but I must
stress it is expensive when you become a
member you'll also get access to our
Discord server to hang out with
like-minded individuals and our
uncensored show Monday through Thursday
10 p.m. we will have one tonight you
don't want to miss it cuz you get to
even call in to talk to us and our guest
now joining us to talk about this and
everything else is the man himself Prime
Time Alex Stein pimp on a blimp
everybody go get that Prime Time grind
coffee it is Hunter Biden approved so
it's going to keep you up all night
that's not true Ukrainian strippers are
not included Yeah well yeah but they're
not we're going to get he's going to
he's going to file us he's going to sue
yeah Sor and they're going to win and
we're going to go to jail but uh I have
nothing to do with Alex Stein's coffee
Alex Stein does more time in prison than
Hunter Biden does shouting him out
wouldn't be surprised no no honestly uh
I really appreciate that and guys we're
going to help some sick cats that's
what's most important I'm not even about
the money I don't need the money honey I
want to help out some of the felines
because you know what I always put the
on the pedestal and I'm talking
about cats YouTube so that's we're
legally allowed to say that right on we
also got Sheamus in town ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls I am glad to be
back here I apologize I've lost my voice
a little bit maybe I shouldn't apologize
for that some of you in the audience
will be very happy to hear it and I
think everyone will be very happy to
hear that I wearing a custom shirt that
I made got move your mic out my Bud he
can't be here tonight but I made a shirt
commemorating myself and my best bud
Luke Luke I I hope you enjoy that uh and
with with his permission since both of
our likenesses are on it possibly we
could we could sell it to commemorate
our friendship am I allow we'll put it
up I guess well I I want I want to make
sure I have my best buds permission
before I sell a shirt with totally fine
I'll just give Luke all the money no the
problem has to he wouldn't want that
Luke is such a good friend that he
wouldn't want that he would want you to
take all the money shouldn't you guys
wait till June to sell a gay pride shirt
no it's just why is male friendship
always seen as homosexual I I got to be
honest that that was that was that's
uncalled for men can be friends that's
true I apologize yes I think you should
not that there's anything wrong with
that we love the gays all right all
right Hannah Clay is hanging out too
yeah it's gonna be a spicy episode with
you guys uh I'm Hanah clay rimel I'm a
writer for cnr.com I'm happy to be here
with these weird boys and serge is here
too thanks yeah not included in weird
boys
weird what's up Alex good to see you man
and likewise Sheamus let's get into it
great to see you man here's the story
from the New York Post Epstein accuser
claims pedophile had sex tapes of trump
Clinton Prince Andrew and Richard
Branson new docs this is false is false
I'm highlighting the New York Post
intentionally for the story because
while the witness did claim that there
are videos of Clinton Prince Andrew and
Branson the witness did not say there
were there were videos of trump which is
very strange that New York Post will put
that in the headline there were two
different sections let's read the story
however Jeffrey epine accuser once
claimed former president Donald Trump
allegedly had relations with one of her
unnamed friends at at je Epstein's home
on regular occasions that is true
according to the the documents that have
have come up Sarah Ransom in a string of
2016 emails to then New York Post
columnist Moren Kellan also claimed she
has copies of the tapes Epstein had made
of some of his high-profile friends
Trump former President Bill Clinton
Prince Andrew and British business
magnet Richard Branson now again I want
to I'm I'm going to say I'm I'm almost
completely positive based on what I had
read Trump is not included in there
being videos of this that was not the
claim quote she confided about confided
in me about her casual friendship with M
with with Donald Mr Trump definitely
seemed to have a thing for her and she
told me how he kept going on how he
liked her per nipples Ransom wrote about
her friend in one email made public when
the latest batch of newly in sealed
documents dropped however they do then
go on to point out Ransom walked back
the salacious allegation in an October
23 2016 email withan writing I would
like to retract everything I have said
to you and walk away from this she added
that only bad things and pain for my
family would come from going public in
2019 Ransom admitted in a New Yorker
article she invented the tapes to draw
attention to Epstein's Behavior Trump
adviser Steven Chun said in a statement
Monday these baseless accusations have
been fully retracted because they are
simply false and have no merit Clinton's
rep Angel Urena declined to comment
Monday a Virginia groups spokesman
spokesperson told the post in a New
Yorker report published in 2019 Ransom
admitted she had invented the tapes we
can confirm that Sarah ransom's claims
are baseless and unfounded Ransom who
has been living abroad since 2017 and
now living in London never produced the
alleged tapes she didn't immediately
return her quest for comment Monday the
emails were filed in a since settled
defamation lawsuit that Epstein accuser
Virginia du fre AKA Virginia Roberts had
brought against the sio's Madame gilain
Maxwell now the first thing I want to
say is they do see seem wild the
allegations outright they do not seem
very credible like my friends got these
tapes I swear they exist oh man don't
you better believe in Donald Trump said
per nipples and it's just like Ah that's
that's tough to believe man innocent
till proven guilty on all all counts now
I will say a few things however in the
documents EP claims to be with friends
with Bill Clinton he says Clinton likes
him young allegedly in some of these
documents Bill Clinton went to vity fair
to try to shut down this uh this
reporting additionally the witness
statement isn't just that there were
videotapes
of of uh Clinton uh Branson and Andrews
I'm sorry prince Andrew but that
additionally so uh FBI potentially
working on Hillary Clinton's behalf went
to her went to her friend and told her
to basically shut up and throw it all
away and apparently got some kind of
settlement to cover it up because
Hillary Clinton wanted to be president
when someone then comes out a few years
later and says my family only pain for
my family and bad things would come from
going public it it's
it's hard to say there's any there's
anything to we we can do here to be
completely honest it's it's almost a
moot point because it's like you make
accusations and you recant them what can
we really say about you but I will add I
don't trust Bill
Clinton I think we all have a good idea
of what Epstein was doing we want to
know who's on those client lists we know
who's flying on these planes Not only
was Donald Trump accused but also in
other documents one witness said Trump
was not there and did not engage in this
Behavior which again throws this
witness's credibility into question but
I will say take it all with a grain of
salt believe believe what you what you
want to believe we don't have anything
definitely definitively proven but I
want to add Jean Luke
brell he ended himself in prison Jeffrey
Epstein ended himself and then I'll add
to both of those so they report
allegedly now when you have stories like
that I'm not surprised a witness who
made these kind of accusations against
the clintons is now like h i I'm sorry I
made it up leave leave me alone I'm out
especially real quick sorry if it were
if they were initially true that a
friend claimed to have these things it's
here say to begin with and that the FBI
or someone tried to pay her off maybe
someone pretend to the FBI who knows
then it's possible when this person came
out and said all of these things are
true my friend said this her friend then
went I got paid I'll never I'll never
admit it I'll never give you the tapes I
think it's very possible that there are
tapes I mean that's how a Honeypot
operation Works where if you want to
Blackmail somebody you have him sleep
with a kid or something and you film and
I mean I know that sounds far-fetched
but we know that Bill Clinton is with
mon lski who was an intern at the time
so he obviously likes youngish type
girls so I don't know I think there's a
lot of smoke and there's a lot of smoke
how was Linsky at the time I like 24 I
think I believe she was 25 26 Still I
mean that's you know relatively young
and so I think he does have a sexual
proclivity to like you know younger he
was 22 Yeah 22 and he was what 58 or
something like that I think he was 58
yeah yeah yeah so I mean that's a pretty
big age no no no he was 49 49 so he was
even a little younger but still I I mean
he's finger banging Monica lsky with a
cigar in the White House well that
that's an incorrect statement or cigar
banging excuse me let me let me well
keep it little family friendly Sor for
YouTube but if he's going to do that
then we know he's a pervert so the idea
that he's on a private island with
Jeffrey Epstein and the fact that if
Jeffrey Epstein was smart you would film
Bill Clinton doing that so you'd have
leverage I mean I think that's the whole
point of his operation and and listen I
don't know if this is true but there's
some rumors I just saw Alan dtz was
getting pressed on whether um Epstein
was a mad agent I don't know if that's
true but I think it's very weird have
you ever heard that you know but but
gain Maxwell's dad you know uh ended up
dying on a boat they say that he worked
for mad so I don't know there's just a
lot of weird connections with this that
are very high high rank I think when it
comes to the Mad stuff I'm kind of like
sure let's get some evidence and on top
of that if someone came to me and said
Epstein was working with mad the CIA MI6
or whatever I'd be like yeah okay
probably I mean look imagine like I I
wonder the possibility Epstein the whole
thing was not that Epstein himself was
the villain but that this was the play
of high high Prof like high high power
High powerered Intelligence agencies who
said we want to control powerful
individuals and world leaders so what do
they do they recruit Epstein who for
some reason goes from was like a high
school teacher to all of a sudden being
worth you know half a billion dollars
and they say here's the play you get
these men to do these things we get the
we get the video what if the black mail
was actually government intelligence
agency blackmail so when people say mad
I'm like sure but what about any other
intelligence agency yeah yeah definitely
I mean my point with this is whether
it's mad whether it's CIA who knows uh
all I know is that people are going to
dismiss all of those accusations is
crazy obviously in the point of mad uh
with the case of mad they're going to
say it's anti-semitic to allege
something like that but the reality is
none of this is off the table because
none of this is crazy we're talking
about a billionaire who had an Island
full of underage children who he was sex
trafficking and we know this was
happening and we know world leaders were
going there the idea that anything is
off the table here with respect to
discussion or that there's some
conspiracy theory here that's too
far-fetched to believe based on the
things we know happened is ridiculous
this is an insane situation and if you
told people that this happened five even
10 years ago they would brush you off as
being completely insane so for people to
know that this happened then for people
to know that this guy quote unquote
killed himself in jail while the guards
were sleep and the security cameras
happened malfunction and somehow hung
himself with toilet paper and go okay
yeah so we know we were basically lied
to about everything and our leaders were
in on this to some extent but that see
the idea that CIA or mad or any of these
organizations are in it that's just
farfetched and crazy have you seen the
the video like someone made a computer
generated model of how Epstein allegedly
jumping off
the he's he's laying with his legs
folded underneath him so like he's doing
like Cannonball kind of but not but like
okay so imagine this uh uh kneel down on
your knees and then sit on your on your
heels and then lay as far back as you
can then spread your legs grab your feet
and launch yourself off of a bed the
video is absolutely ridiculous because
the bed was not high enough and so
someone post a video but like first I
saw the official report of like
explaining how he did it then someone
was like here's what it looks like in a
video and I'm like this is the stupidest
thing I have ever seen okay but maybe I
guess at the same time the guards fell
asleep and the camera stopped working y
yeah nobody believ that yeah no it's
ridiculous and I I want to flag one more
thing here just because you already know
what the response from certain
organizations to this will be but like
if thinking that mad is up to something
Sketcher has done anything wrong as
anti-semitic that means believing that
the CIA or FBI or any American
organization being up to something bad
somehow means that you hate Americans or
the United States in general but I think
that's what they want right I mean yeah
they don't want you to be able to
criticize any of these intelligence
right and all the intelligence agencies
came from a time when there was higher
trust in federal government and we have
shifted so far away from that that it's
really you know not to be mean to the
Boomers but it's really an older
generation that looks at you and says
but they would never it's the younger
generation that is like we grew up in
the reality where you can actually prove
a lot of this stuff instead of the
narrative being controlled by the
government and sort of a a closed
circuit of media organizations there are
there's so much more uh independent
journalism that sort of calls attention
to these things so it's it's really your
grandparents your parents maybe that are
are saying you you can't criticize the
federal government because they're here
to help us like no one R age actually
believes that I think on either side of
the political aisle really and well not
and not only is it things that we can
prove as Outsiders that they've done
which are horrible but they've admitted
to things that are just absolutely
Unthinkable people are pointing out I
think rightly so if there were tapes of
trump these would have been released in
2016 this is like the most investigated
man on the entire planet you're telling
me this wouldn't have come up sooner
yeah 2016 before before the
they claim they CLA AE of trump never
produced my favorite Trump Alle was the
somewhere something may have happened
with Trump in an elevator but who knows
what and when and we haven't found the
video you remember that one what about
Tom Arnold had a show looking for the
tapes of him saying the nword you
remember that supposedly he said the
nword on The Apprentice and there's a
whole show on Vice of Tom Arnold yes you
guys didn't see this he just watched
like hours and hours of The Apprentice
it was like kind of like a fake
documentary where he was like yeah like
he was like going to the producers or
the sound guy the sound engineer that
worked on the show trying to find it
yeah if this if if Donald Trump was with
a child on ep's island that would
probably be out but I still I don't put
Donald Trump and Bill Clinton on the
same boat I think one isse the other
have you guys watched the new season of
It's Always Sunny I I watched most of
the one of the episodes they find out
that Frank was hanging out on the island
on and they were like you went to the
island for snorkeling I didn't know
anything about the kid stuff well you
know there are some celebrities that
went there that didn't know but what
would you say that the breakdown is what
do you think the breakdown is if they
knew I feel like if you were going there
you're in circle I mean here's here's
here's how the scenario reportedly or
allegedly plays out some dude who's like
wealthy and Powerful gets invited to fly
on his plane because like let's say
you're in New York you meet him at a
conference and then he goes hey we're
going to be flying down to uh on my
private jet to to to the Keys you got a
weekend you want to come hang out we'll
we'll hang out we'll have coconuts and
they're like wow that sounds great they
go on this plane and then a young woman
comes out and he's like oh meet this
young woman the young woman then entices
the guy ah you know but she's being
trafficked she's being pressured to do
this and made to do this by Epstein the
rich powerful dude doesn't realize
what's going on Epstein films it and
then as soon as the plane lands he puts
his hand on his shoulder and says she's
underage we filmed It All We own you now
that's allegedly how it how it plays out
well Alex Jones said this exact scenario
years ago he was like these guys are on
planes having sex with children and
you're like yeah right now now now the
kid stuff those guys no question they
know but in terms of the capturing and
and like getting celebrities and
tricking them it's like you get a girl
who's 16 you claim she's 18 then the
celebrity is drunk stupid and on drugs
and you got them I mean these are aoral
people to begin with don't get me wrong
these people are I'm going to go party
on a plane and you know everybody know
knows what his plane was called
everybody knew what he was doing back in
like 2008 2010 well have you seen the
memes where it says Stephen Hawking
would like to have undressed dwarves do
complicated math problems
like they couldn't reach on the
chalkboard I did see that I think that's
fake but that's what they said is one of
his
sexualties was a joke he want to see I
think that has to be a joke but Stephen
Hawking was on the plane went to the
island supposedly I think that he had to
build him some sort of special a
wheelchair ramp or dock or some sort of
way to get him on a boat so I mean a
compliance yeah no seriously they had to
build something so I I mean do you think
Stephen Hawking knew that he was doing I
mean this is all alleged you know I mean
that's interesting Hawking went to the
island is that is that is that that's
what they say yeah I don't know is that
true or is it I I mean I think it's
pretty true whatever they News Guard
rating not good look look if if if
someone asked me to take $100 and put it
on Hawking knew or didn't know he knew
I'm just going to I'm just going to bet
every time that anybody who flew on his
plane and went to his let's say this
anybody who went to his Island like I
really do not see a scenario where they
don't know what's going on yeah also
like isn't Stephen Hawking supposed to
have been one of the smartest people who
ever lived and like he didn't know he
knew nothing of what everything was up
to and would just focus on the science
he had no he's on the plane and he's
like I can theorize about blackes but I
didn't see anything wink wink Jeffrey
yeah yeah no I think ultimately if you
were going to the island Jeffrey Epstein
wanted you to see what was going on
there which means either you were okay
with it or maybe it is entrapment I
think it's the plane starts to be like
maybe he was like oh I'm a billionaire
I'll get you feeling comfortable with me
whatever I could see a couple scenarios
like people who are photographed at with
him at parties right like you may not
know who he is
it's circumstantial at best but the
island is somewhere and any of his other
properties he had that that big one in
Arizona you know if he's taking you to
his private properties where he is
keeping young women that seems like he
wants you to see but here's here's
another
scenario Epstein you know says hey you
know want to come hang out on my Island
we're going to go jet ski and snorkel
it's going to be fun you land you get
out let's say you get on the plane and
and some young girl comes out oh I'm
married I can't do it goes okay the
plane lands and then then you see what's
going on he then turns to you and says
we'll kill you if you tell anybody and
if you don't tell anybody you're a
complicit welcome to being an accomplice
e even if the people refused it's
basically your choice of go up against
Epstein and Bill Clinton and all these
other high-profile people who are
involved so what are you going to do you
going to report him good luck how do you
like this is the question with what Joe
Biden is doing on the southern border
who do you report Joe Biden to
is there a superior Authority in law
enforcement who can stop the bid
Administration from facilitating these
crimes on the southern border that's it
MH he's a commander-in-chief so if you
fly in this plane you know Bill
Clinton's been on you know that Clinton
is friends with this guy and then he
says who are you going to tell Bill
Clinton's my buddy the Secret Service
knows exactly what he's doing good luck
well there's nobody you can Best Buds
and he makes a t-shirt there there's
nobody you can tell don't compare them
to us don't compare them to luk to my
best luk I just occurred to me that
possibly no but Tim you made one of the
biggest connections and what's happening
at the southern border you know whether
you want to say it's like the great
replacement Theory but a lot of it I'm
telling you and I'm not saying this is
some right-wing conspiracy theorist sex
trafficking is a huge business to the
cartel it is huge and a lot of what's
happening is driven by sex with underage
kids not necessarily just because people
want to sleep with children but also
they're more vulnerable I mean there's
there's a Litany of reasons why they use
children but it is kind of connected to
Epstein in a weird way that these people
that are empowered do not even care that
kids are literally getting traded you
know like drugs well I hate to say this
but like probably there are people in
power who specifically heard Epstein had
this kind of connection and sought him
out like that's who aoral a lot of did
you guys see Jim Gaffigan's joke yeah he
was at the Golden Globes and he's like I
can't believe I'm here you know I'm from
a small town I'm not a
pedophile yeah there's something to be
said for what you just mentioned Alex
about the fact that there is a lot of
trafficking that takes place here and
not only is it the case that our media
does everything to turn to Blind Eye to
it and that elected officials
particularly on the left do everything
to have people not notice it it's that
you are actually actively maligned and
smeared if you point that out or you say
anything about it or you want to
implement any practical measures to
prevent it from occurring so for example
when border security separates the
children from the adults that they are
with in order to vet them to make sure
that they aren't being trafficked that's
separating children from their parents
and that's just Unthinkable Dare You ex
starting with the assum that they're the
parents even though you have no idea who
these people are and they're illegally
trespassing into your country and if you
you do anything to try to investigate to
vet to make sure that those kids aren't
being traffic you're separating children
from their parents you're a horrible
person how you that's so creepy I
remember that when when you know we had
these stories and they're like they're
separating the children from the parents
and it's like some guy with a little
girl and no ID yeah and they're
supposedly do DNA tests to connect them
but how long does that take to come back
I mean that's just such BS like they
actually can tell oh this is their
biological son yeah right so let's uh
let's jump to this next story from the
New York Post cuz this one's got big
implications for 2024 a a top strategist
for JP Morgan predicts that Joe Biden
will drop out of the 2024 race in March
and I agree I believe uh that there's a
strong likelihood that Joe Biden will
drop out and it all makes a lot of sense
now when we were talking about Nome this
is last year we're like Newsome's
probably going to be the guy Joe Biden
drops out a bunch of people Super Chat
into the show saying it's too late Tim
they can't hold a primary now so it's
Biden or no one wrong this is the
perfect play Joe Biden stays in and then
through no fault of his own oh no a
medical issue oh he's having heart
murmur or something he can drop out then
the DNC says well this is a catastrophe
for us I mean what do we do it's too
late to have a primary guest will have
to just appoint a nominee sorry
progressives no Bernie Sanders for you
no Jen yuger no RFK Jr it's going to
have to be
Gavin Newsome or Big Mike yes Michelle
Obama I mean I think that's a big
possibility I think Michelle would win I
mean I think there I mean I think I
would have thought so a year ago I'm not
so sure today not anymore no no because
Trump's winning among the in in the
youth vote in numerous po jtim this is
like you actually have faith in the
election process I mean I I know we can
only say so much on YouTube but I mean
no YouTube allows you to say the
election I know can now but I still
don't like messing with the terms of
service I just I I just really have such
little faith in our future election and
I think if they take him off the ballot
Trump lost by only what like 44,000 or
something it like three states you know
like 11,000 votes in each state or some
exactly so if you if you think that for
all of their efforts that's the margin
they won by and now with Trump the polls
are inverted Trump was down in the polls
and and got and and only lost by like
40K votes imagine where he's going to be
now I mean they could like they can try
and cheat all they want and they're
going to and it's going to be
embarrassing for them they're not going
to have the same level of boutot
harvesting to to assist Joe Biden they
would have to go fullscale fraud to try
and cheat this gu did you know this stat
from the past election Donald Trump won
every single state from their inperson
voting Joe Biden won every single state
with mailin voting for the first time
yes he even won The Bluest States in MA
in inperson voting Trump did wow yes and
the uh bellweather counties that
typically always have been always
correct this time we're all completely
wrong except for one and just the energy
he had compared to Joe Biden there' be
like four people at the Biden rally well
and Biden didn't go anywhere he was like
basically campaigning from his house
that's what I mean there were like four
housekeepers in his basement yeah it's
like all of his kids and grandkids are I
think the bulk of what worked for
Democrats was ballot harvesting yep you
combine ballot harvesting with lax
signature verification what do you get a
guy election in history Tim how dare you
oh sure a guy goes to a nursing home and
then says I'm here to collect bouts for
I'm here to make sure everyone voted
then goes to all these old people and
says just check this box and now sign it
and all these signatures are wacky
because these these older people have no
idea what's going on and then signature
verification was way LAX in many of
these places and even then Trump still
only lost by like 50 or so thousand
votes you take a look at uh uh the Trump
campaign put out a b a big list of all
the states where they think that he
should have won and the margins are
microscopic 10,000 here 3,000 there
with Trump's polling today with numerous
polls showing that he's he's uh uh he's
beating Joe Biden in the youth vote the
Democrats absolutely must remove Joe
Biden and bring in Gavin Newsome or
Michelle Obama because if Joe Biden runs
and they keep him in and they do not
remove him from the from the nomination
or from from from the candidacy Trump
wins their only play is going to be Joe
Biden you are out someone else comes in
do you think Nome has enough support
among young
progressives sometimes I feel like they
are not they are not willing to have
another white male be the leader of
their party and that does matter I'll
tell everybody right now right now in
2020 everyone says Trump had all the
energy and
enthusiasm but Joe bid because Joe Biden
had no favorability like no no
enthusiasm the polling was like 20
something perent 24 26 Trump's was like
90 enthusiasm against Trump to oppose
him was higher than enthusiasm for Trump
creating a big opportunity so I will
tell you this right now the polls show
that if it's Trump V Biden Trump crushes
Biden in every way but they also say
Trump versus anyone else and he loses by
a little bit we will see considering the
polls were heavily against Trump and
he's still only lost by like 44k votes
even if the polls are saying Trump set
you know 49 to other candidates 50 or
whatever it's still indicative of a
trump victory
I do think however the most important
thing imaginable is everybody's got to
go campaign you got to knock on doors
you got to register people to vote you
got to follow Scott Pressler on Twitter
and just when he says here's how we
register people here's how we get them
to vote that's what you got to do and
you got to recognize if the Republicans
are not preparing for the law fair it's
already over you've already lost 2024
election well I think Elon must said it
it's like whatever the most entertaining
outcome is probably what's going to
happen and to what you're saying Hannah
is like you'd think that you'd want this
Multicultural Progressive you know CA
Harris type candidate but I think that
irony they're going to do the opposite
and they get another blue blood Joe
Biden white guy like gavan it's like the
opposite of what you expect so that's
why I think that he probably has a
chance but does he have the uh support
behind him no I don't think so that's
the thing like Joe Biden's completely
unpopular everyone thinks he's too old
including every poll that they do do
about him youth vote is not motivated
for him he's not gaining there but they
don't really have anyone else I mean I
don't think they want it to be Biden but
I don't think Michelle would win I don't
think Gavin necessarily holds at least
long term maybe they could sneak through
in kind of a desperate attempt but I
don't know that people actually want him
to be the face of the party right now
they're very divided we saw this with
all of with everything that came out
with um the Israel Hamas conflict I mean
the Democrats had to look themselves in
the eyes and say we are a split party
even though we pretending that we are in
lock step this whole time they're not if
John fedman runs would we vote for John
fedman who's we who's just saying I mean
would we would you like a fedman
presidency if he was a democratic
nominee I mean what we do know is if he
was running against Dr Oz the nation
would probably pick him yeah I mean
fedman has become sort of amusing but I
wouldn't vote for him my favorite
Democrat probably right yeah he's he was
he was defending Israel and he called
out the crisis on the southern border so
I'm like well you know take what you can
get I guess yeah but maybe that's the
future for a lot of Democrats I mean we
used to say this about Joe Mansion right
he was the last the blue dog Democrats
he represented a different time and
maybe the fact that he's leaving the
Senate and several other people are
starting to think hey this party is
drifting too far I need to start tacking
back towards what used to be considered
the Middle it's probably still just the
left that's right well this has happened
in the past right so right after the
Reagan Era Democrats realized that they
had to be more conservative in order to
get elected so when you look at campaign
ads from people like Bill Clinton back
in the early 90s it's a different kind
of democrat who's more moderate and
wants to roll back the welfare state and
that's probably What's Happening Now
Democrats are realizing that they have
to move to the right or at least a
little bit closer to the center on
certain issues because of how far
they've swung to the left and we really
saw this back in 2022 or 2021 with Joe
Biden's State of the Union Address we
watched it on this show and he was
really going on and on with talking
points that were basically lifted from
Trump about how we need to defend the
police and secure the southern border I
I got to push back on what what Alex
said however which is not your quote but
Elon Musk that the most entertaining
outcome you know tends to be likely or
whatever something like that something
like that yeah like the the the outcome
that's most entertaining is what's going
to happen more likely something what it
sounds like it's it's it's incorrect
it's it's a point to be made that a lot
of entertaining outcomes are happening
but the most entertaining outcome
absolutely not the most entertaining
outcome in this race would be if like
tomorrow someone saw Trump and Biden
walking down the street in DC holding
hands and when they were asked why
they're doing it they explain that
they're simply sharing proteins and he
and then he asked protein strands can
you think of a better way exactly right
Simpson's reference like the most
entertaining outcome would be like a a
Joe Biden and Donald Trump playing Petty
cake in the White House lawn and us
being confused and just laughing about
the absurdity of it no the reality is
it's going to be likely the most
shocking in terms of entertaining okay
maybe this entertaining maybe is the
wrong way to describe it but perhaps the
right word because you know like die
hard is entertaining which involves a
lot of explosions and people dying yeah
well as you say that I mean what do you
think the possibility is they can't get
Trump off the ballot and I would never
want this to happen obviously but what
if they did a Lee Harvey Oswell type
situation I mean do you think that's
possible in this day and age where there
could be a presidential assassination
flag false
FL already tried to take tr's life in
the in his first run in it was 2015 I
think a guy at a rally tried grabbing a
gun from from a cop I think it was
because he was trying to uh let's just
say seriously hurt Donald Trump um but I
think the
likelihood that there is like a deep
State attempt on the life of the
president you know in any capacity be it
Trump Biden or anybody else is very very
very low yeah what you need is character
disgrace not martyrdom if someone look
we see this all the time with
politicians
assassinations will stop a politician
and immortalize their
ideas and hold on and an assassination
attempt boosts their popularity and
ensures their victory yeah would he what
would his legacy be if he I mean if that
happened would it be positive or
negative for all of the Trump supporters
and for everyone who comes after he
would be he would be a legacy he he he
already is going to be like the the the
the you know who's he's already a martyr
no they say who is the who is the heir
of Maga right people are saying V ramas
Swami already Donald Trump is viewed
this way but if if someone were to take
his life all they would do is
dramatically Empower Maga 100 fold yeah
they would so that is not the play and
and I think ultimately More Than You
Know The Enemy you know is better right
like the the Democrats know who to
attack with Trump they kind of know his
weaknesses and they also position him as
the party of the past that's what Biden
said in his first campaign speech right
the Maga party is focused on the past
but we're the future and then spends the
rest of his 30-minute speech saying so
this is what happened three years ago
and why it's bad and all the
repercussions I mean they really want it
to be Trump because they think they know
their enemy and whip up hysteria against
him if if something were to happen to
him an unknown candidate like vake or
someone else would be almost more
challenging and therefore it's bad I
think there's truth in that I'll also
mention this uh because I slightly
disagree with what Tim said I right I
don't I'm not making any prediction that
Trump is going to be assassinated or
that there's going to be attempt on his
life but I will say they have repeatedly
tried to assassinate his character and
it hasn't worked with his base and it
hasn't worked with a lot of the country
and if anything it's just made people
more skeptical of the media and so at
some point if there really is a
conspiracy to take a person out you go
from trying to assassinate their
character in media if that doesn't work
some kind of conspiracy to try to
imprison them and if that doesn't work
you really only have one option left
even if it is a thing that'll turn him
into a martyr because what it does is it
sends a message to the next person who
might stand up and for that position
that they're going to have the same
outcome as the last guy well and you
really think about it though it's just
an illusion that we have that we
actually have choice of rer left because
like I mean let's say it is not Trump
let's say they kick him off the ballot
then we have listen I like some of what
Dan santis did in Florida but I mean
Nikki Haley who's being so propped up by
The Establishment even just said that
the illegal immigrants across the border
aren't criminals I mean so that's right
that offensive to call them that that's
what she just said so it's like give me
a break that you think Nikki Haley is
all of a sudden I mean we don't have
anybody on the right that's really going
to be our savior and that's why we say
this on the show all the time it's
idolizing a politician it's like
thinking the stripper actually likes you
you know we just it's all a facade it's
all fake really I I trust V yeah I like
no I do too I trust yeah I will say I
trust Trump to be Trump I have trust in
V but let me clarify that doesn't mean
that I trust him absolutely it's 51% you
know what I mean like we'll see what he
can do he's just some guy talking to us
right now I'll say this well uh back
when when Tim was gone for a week and I
had the honor of of Hosting shim cast
for a week for was the worst week of the
show ever without question it was awful
we bombed in the ratings and everyone
hates me super chats were way down don't
forget how low super super low but one
one advantage was I also made vake hate
me cuz he had to sit through a two-hour
interview with me but through that
two-hour interview I was really I mean I
did no I really appreciated his answers
I he wasn't just giving me political
talking points he went very deep on the
issues he was talking about things like
how Duties are are are or I'm sorry how
rights are a product of Duty and not the
other way around I was like that's like
I say that all the time um and I really
appreciated the fact that he had a very
thought out worldview on the philosophy
rather than just a series of policy
positions because someone who's really
thought out about their philosophy who
genuinely wants to bring those ideals to
fruition in the real world they're going
to be a lot harder to get to flip-flop
on certain issues because it's now it's
not just like a platform of issues that
you can kind of compromise on it's a
whole entire worldview that you're going
to want to hold to and that you're going
to want to represent honestly and they
have a way to navigate challenges they
don't have to have they have they have a
a framework from which they can make
ethical decisions I mean the is a really
interesting guy you know I've said this
a couple times if he is you know not the
VP or whatever I would love to see him
run in Ohio because I think he is the
kind of person who could breathe energy
into you know a state that for for all
intensive person needs a little bit of
of boost I mean it's a it's a very nice
state but you know there's not a ton of
industry there as far as I know there
isn't a ton of uh young people moving in
and staying there it could use strong
leadership and so I think with vake
there is a chance that he is able to do
something on a small scale and then
potentially in 2028 win people over
people who sort of weren't sure he was
on test quantity he will just lose the
If he if he runs for another office he
does lose the edge of being The Outsider
the non politician but does that matter
if you have a proven track record of
positivity exactly and what he gains is
again the track record and the
experience one thing I think is
hilarious and ridiculous about American
politics is people put so much emphasis
on experience that they are actually
more willing to have someone who has
experience but all of it has been a
complete disaster and they've destroyed
everything they've touched rather than
someone who's an outsider coming in who
has experienced in the private sector
and has done tremendous things in the
private sector doing things that are
arguably far more difficult than public
sector work or elected office so people
go well vake he just doesn't have the
experience in government it's like okay
but a lot of these other people do have
experience in government it's all awful
and they they've destroyed everything
that they've had the opportunity to lead
the experience they have is how to
exploit yes their position in government
yes and V's really smart he's married to
a surgeon he was you know he's just a
smart guy independently wealthy and and
I think also one you know and all the
staunch Republicans are going to get mad
but that he did have liberal views and
he's changed his viewpoints at a young
age I'm just saying that's kind of the
ultimate person is that seen both sides
so I I do think that's why he's so
successful too is that he's a disruptor
he's saying hey let's get rid of the FBI
let's get rid of all these alphabet
agencies so I mean he's saying all the
right stuff let's just see if you can
let's talk about the real threat here
the when it comes to the election people
people need to consider uh uh this
immigration Mexico demands Biden give
amnesty to 10 million illegal immigrants
in exchange for help with border crisis
a record high of 300,000 illegal
immigrants were processed by Customs and
Border Protection in December it's
criminal they're criminals and now Joe
Biden's likely going I I'm willing to
bet no matter what happens this year be
it Biden or Trump Biden rubber stamp
some kind of amnesty 10 million illegal
immigrants instantly being granted
amnesty will forever change this country
and there is nothing you can do
understand this you you why is it that
the Biden Administration has been
trafficking illegal immigrants to all of
these different cities what did we see
with Co we saw the more
conservative-minded individuals fleeing
to Texas and Florida Florida turns deep
red everybody comes out and says oh
Ronda sandis you're the greatest
Governor I did a good job but let's
let's also consider the fact that with
all of these people moving into Miami
moving into Florida for Refuge that has
Stripped Away a large portion of the
more right-leaning voters and voter base
in these places which will now be
replaced by illegal immigrants who are
being trafficked into Chicago into New
York into these liberal places the first
thing that it will do is in the in in in
this census in the next census it will
give an imp balance of power to
Democrats it is estimated that
California has between one and maybe
even as high as seven extra
congressional seats and electoral votes
based on illegal immigrant population
because the census calculates all people
not all citizens and congressional seats
represent people not citizens that's
insane I think it was Thomas Mass who
said he has an amendment to make it so
that Congress only represents citizens
with 10 million illegal immigrants
coming into this country and being
shipped alone
Joe Biden can rubber stamp amnesty in
executive order it'll be unopposed there
will be challenges I'm sure but for the
most part no everyone's going to sit
back and watch and what's going to
happen is these people will instantly
start registering and you you are
basically giving Democrats a massive
majority in the voting block if amnesty
happens this right here Mexico demanding
it will be the justification for why Joe
Biden does give them amnesty and and
he'll say he'll say exactly what Ronald
Reagan did we're going to secure the
Border we're going to enforce our laws
and the deal we have is to start we
Grant amnesty to those already here and
then we lock things down that's exactly
what Ronald Reagan did when he stabbed
us all in the back and I'm sick of these
these these conservatives who are like
Ronald Reagan was the best are you
kidding and they argue yeah but the
amnesty wasn't that many people look
what it did to California it's not just
California following this this is in the
' 80s into the 9s you end up with the
next generation of individuals when they
passing a proposition 187 in California
that said non-citizens cannot have
access to the public to public goods it
it led to protests in Mass Revolt why
because they brought in a large portion
of non-citizens granted them citizenship
and these non-citizens have deeper ties
to their families as they should and
they will always vote on behalf of their
families so instead of getting people to
immigrate here to assimilate and
integrate here they get a bunch of
people who broke the law to enter this
country grant them benefits to our
public goods then the right to vote
surprise surprise they voted on behalf
of their home countries and their
families which is completely
unsurprising anyone would do it with
this migrant crisis if there is not a
mass deportation if Mexico's demands are
fulfilled and Biden plays the same game
as Reagan that's it American values get
erased overnight no I agree and I think
10 million would be like the e biggest
state so no I I agree with you a th% I
think they are probably going to do some
sort of amnesty and then it just flips
all the voting districts and I didn't
realize that Califoria gets eight extra
congressionals so there's there's
estimates I think it was um I'm not sure
which organization a few years ago there
was in it says in 2020 when they're
doing the new census California loses a
seat some estimates said it's it's one
or two seats perhaps they get extra now
those seats also mean Electoral College
votes yeah yeah however with um the this
bill that I think it wasn't uh uh
drafted uh by Massie but it was
sponsored the Republicans actually
estimate 5 to S extra electoral votes
for Democrats based on people who are
not citizens this is the mistake made by
so many people we are not a democracy so
I was I don't know if you guys saw that
Zero Hedge debate with the CR Destiny
Destiny and Alex that was crazy Alex and
Destiny are a match made in heaven
because the way they just yell over each
other but in this Alex Jones correctly
points out it doesn't matter if they
vote what matters is this is a republic
in which case as long as Congress
represents non-citizens their vote is
rep their their their will is
represented at the federal level for the
president and for our laws and the only
thing the left were saying was illegal
immigrants don't vote illegal immigrants
don't vote over and over again that
doesn't matter we are a republic not a
democracy we vote for a representative
if a representative is is if if a
district is created because there's
750,000 noncitizens those non-citizens
get representation in Congress and then
they they effectively get their vote
yeah well and so yeah you're you're
exactly right they'll say well they
don't vote okay but their presence does
sway elections their their presence does
affect elections they'll say other
things well they they don't receive
welfare benefits that's also not true
well I mean you guys are constantly
saying that taxes pay for churches
because church is not paying taxes but
their parishioners using public services
means that they're taking from the
system okay well guess what illegals
don't pay taxes and they take from the
system and you don't consider that to be
theft and on top of that they will have
one citizen in the family who can take
welfare living with five or 10 illegals
who are receiving the welfare from them
so yes illegals are they just approve
free healthare in California for illegal
IM true let's pause here let's pause
here the Democrats argue that they don't
they either don't receive benefits or
they're paying in let me just stop you
right there and we'll go as rudimentary
as we can have you you complained about
potholes lately yes more people means
more wear and tear on your roads
someone's going to pay for that the
roads are going to have to be fixed more
frequently because there's more people
in your city that's it so if you're
wondering why it is your water bill goes
up if you're wondering why it is that
your the cost of electric is going up
it's because demand is increasing quite
a bit wear and tear is increasing Ro
there's going to be more road
construction there's going to be more
density density related problems more
students per classroom Transportation
more students per classroom that's right
more crowded trains
so if you are if you are the kind I've
heard from so many people remember when
what was it KFC filled the potholes was
it
KFC restaurant I think it was Domino's
it was like a delivery thing I got to
look into that let me let me check well
I think there's a guy that has like a
Tik Tok page where he goes and fixes
pothole he has millions of followers
Kentucky Fried Chicken sponsored pothole
repairs Domino's did too Domino's did
they'd fill the hole and then they would
stamp their logo on the hole and say hey
we fixed this for you what what causes
these potholes what you end up there's a
lot of things that can cause potholes
but it's basically a lot of starting and
stopping you start and stop and then it
causes you know pressure hits and then
huge trucks big trucks driving the more
people you bring into a city and they're
bringing them in in Mass hundreds of
thousands per month you will see more
wear and tear and you're going to pay
for that so when everyone was
complaining that we had pothole problems
that weren't being fixed to the point
where fast food company started doing it
themselves as
advertising this is caused by higher
population density that's that's that's
it and if you're okay with paying the
bills and dealing with the stresses of
population density by all means but this
means there's going to be more crime
food's going to be more expensive
parking will be non-existent it's
already very crowded in New York it's
crazy now just keep adding more people
and see how that goes I mean also we
know for a fact that they're not willing
to pay any of the costs associated with
increased migration they're just okay
with people who live in Border towns or
in states that are being flooded to have
to pay those costs as soon as they get
imported into their neighborhoods they
freak out and shoe all of them away they
actually called the National Guard and
we saw that in Martha's Vineyard yeah
you see Eric Adams is suing the bus
companies now instead of going after the
government I don't know if you saw that
he's suing the actual coach sounds about
right but he's acting out of desperation
I mean he just can't do anything to save
New York from immigration except to to
move IM illegal immigrants to other
counties in New York that didn't want
this to happen in the first place I mean
the reality is that Republicans failed a
long time ago by not being more
proactive about immigration and now
we're seeing the the result of this and
I think part of it is that we have to
take it more seriously and not be afraid
of the consequences of that like the the
big deter for a long time was like oh
these people need help the we you know
whatever I can understand a
compassionate response to people who are
legitimately stressed but now the whole
world knows that you can come to America
and say I am here to claim Asylum and
you don't need any credible proof we'll
schedule hear hearing way later there's
no evidence of this I mean our
immigration system makes us weak and I
don't understand why more people
wouldn't take that seriously they want
the country to be weak and that's why
they do take it seriously they're very
serious about ensuring the problem gets
worse yeah which is crazy I I think this
is what's so interesting about the
possible impeachment of aandra mayorcas
which is like he is derelict in Duty
right there are laws in the book that
his office is actively fought against uh
enforcing there have been times that he
you remember the the the whipping story
this idea that like it was
ridiculous they were carrying whips they
were on a horse it was they did not whip
any migrants and aleandra mayorcas went
to Congress and was like it was crazy
and I I I denounce this and whatever
else he sold out border agents he's not
even representing the people in his
office or in his who are within his
purview to uh advocate for and P and
respect who are trying to do the job
that they were asked to do I mean it's a
system that's completely designed to
fail and yet the Democrats are going to
push for it for longer I just don't get
it at all did you see in Brazil I think
in 2024 you have to show that you have
$2,000 in your bank account to get a
visa to go to Brazil to to get a visa to
go to Brazil yes you need to show a bank
bank statement $2,000 it makes sense I
know got let anybody in I know but
that's no that's real that's not
conspiracy so yeah I mean obviously we
should have some sort of regulations but
I know people that graduated from like
SMU and TCU which are schools in Dallas
that were International students that
immediately had to you know get the hell
out of the country so it's crazy that we
kick out the students but literally you
can be like a convicted you know pervert
you just have to come across the border
and say the right things and then they
let you and did you see how many
migrants are from Haiti they're like
Haitian most of them are not from Mexico
majority are not thing Mexico is like
we'll help you but also we are not
really stopping anyone from entering our
country you know theoretically with a
lot of the stuff if you're claiming
amnesty you're supposed to stop in the
first country and it said they're like
yep keep going to America sounds great
fly to Canada enter through the northern
border I didn't even I want to jump to
uh this story it's a tweet from Alx DC
us attorney Matthew Graves is making
clear the doj is now going to Target
Americans who were around the capital on
January 6 but did not enter the building
as we enter this
2024 understand that uh it's only just
begun and I've made this I I I I made
this warning uh before after this I said
they're going to go after journalists
which they're doing Y and uh uh without
calling out any of these individuals we
uh I've talked to some journalists and
we all know Steve Baker Blaze
contributor is is being targeted and
I've told these these guys hey look man
they're like I have I have a
congressional uh uh press pass I have a
press pass and I'm like you think that
matters with what we saying you think
that matters look the Democrats will
cheer for it and they'll make up some
argument as to why you as a journalist
should get locked up the kenin will will
play defense where they the people like
the kenes will come out and say I don't
know if journalists should be getting
arrested but I really do think the
courts should decide and when they do
that's the right choice then a heavily
biased jury will hear that a
conservative journalist was in the
capital and they will say you should go
to prison I want to play this clip for
you so you can hear exactly what the uh
DC's attorney had to say it's only 30
seconds long inside in the building and
important note when it comes to our
prosecutions about those who remained
outside the
building we have used our prosecutorial
discretion to primarily focus on those
who enter the building or those who
engaged in violent or corrupt conduct on
Capital
grounds but if a person normally entered
the restricted area without
authorization they had already committed
a federal crime make no mistake
thousands of people occupied an area
that they were not authorized to be
present in in the first place let's
let's let's break down what he said
people who knowingly then he says
thousands of people as if to imply all
of them what's coming next I think is
going to shock the psyche of the
American people when we go from what do
we at a thousand or so prosecutions or
convictions 890 some odd years Joe Biden
was bragging about about it's going to
be wild when they've been setting up
these Capital police officers across the
country we know they did it in Florida
and California it's going to be wild
when you could have been someone who was
just just standing there in the grass
yeah Owen Shroyer didn't go in the
building he went to prison the president
is already there you did not have to go
in the building to get arrested Owen
Shroyer now thousands of people are at
risk hey here's an easy way to remove
thousands of trump voters arrest them so
they can't vote don't be surprised if
come August we start seeing Mass raids
overnight po just people getting locked
up we won't even know these people are
take a look at the censorship waves of
Twitter we all know about the
high-profile censorship but the big play
when Twitter was censoring people was
they were targeting small accounts that
no one knew about or could defend a
trump supporter with 300 followers gets
banned who's he going to tell and who's
going to report it the same thing will
start happening but I believe the next
play is going to be to go after people
who posted on social media before
January 6th in support of January 6th
there are high-profile individuals
tweeting out support for violence now we
know that you can be Ray EPs and
Advocate people crash into the building
y several times and guide people there
and you will get recommendation I think
what six months and if you're Enrique
Toro who wasn't even in DC 20 years what
do you think's going to happen to the
people who are on social media in the
weeks leading up to January 6 who were
saying that people
should engage in these activities I want
to clarify I'm not talking about a guy
who went on social media and said I
think people should protest protest and
no no no they may come after that kind
of stuff I'm talking about there were
high-profile commentators who were
saying that people should engage in more
let's just call it direct actions
including physical protests on the
grounds up to the point like of entering
the building let's not be naive up until
January 6 a lot of people were calling
for a big protest I mean I'm saying but
the left was calling left was
calling I don't I I'm not worried about
the people who are being like we got a
protest in DC I'm saying there were
high-profile people with hundreds of
thousands of followers saying things
like storm the building they will come
after those people we've already seen
some people flee the country some you
know about some you've never heard of
but people who were there funny funny
they're gone I mean they post on social
media I'm not going to say their names
but I would not be surprised to find
that it's this there's one guy couple
hundred thousand subscribers one day we
hear the feds rated him I was never in
DC I was never there and they're like
here's multiple videos of you telling
people to engage in criminal activity
you're under arrest well that's who
they'd want to get more than somebody
that was there they want somebody that
has more influence so I wouldn't be yeah
no I wouldn't be surprised but what they
did was entament they knew there was FBI
agents there I mean whether they tell us
that they're there or not so uh this we
talked about Jeffrey upstein earlier
about the Honeypot this was the biggest
Honeypot of our entire uh generation I
believe because a lot of people knew
what was going on that day like the FBI
they knew that there were going to be
people there we talked about this
earlier the maglocks people wouldn't
have got in the building if somebody
didn't press a button to let them in so
there's a video of people there were
already people inside they climbed
through windows but there was a big
crowd at a door that was mag locked
magnetically locked there's a video
where people walk up to it like three or
four people they turn around and look up
and point to the door someone hits the
release seen it could be a protester who
broke in
it could be a security who knows but I
will say even CNN has reported on more
than one occasion evidence that police
fanned people in two stories one you've
got CNN reporting Joe Scarborough's
outrage over the fact that police let
people in the building and open the
doors CNN reports Joe Scarboro says you
effing opened the doors for them to the
capital police CNN also reported on a
man who was acquitted because the judge
agreed the police waved him into the
building now now I just like to point
out real quick to the CNN guys who are
trying to rag on uh V Gras Swami the
definition of inside job you know the
definition of inside job is it's
actually really really really light let
me uh just pull it up for you a crime
committed by or with the assistance of a
person living or working on the premises
where it
occurred so if uh the police effing
opened the door as CNN reported Joe
Scarboro complained about I would call
that an inside job wouldn't you of
course I mean I think it's pretty
obvious that obviously the government
knew that they were going to come in and
when you talk about people getting
prosecuted for just being around I mean
Tim they created uh a lot of people
would have just got misim trespassing
but they created if you I think what is
it uh you interrupted a federal meeting
now they're all charged with felonies
now so I mean the idea that they're
going to go after people that just were
bystand you know just bystanders outside
no they're going to go after everybody I
mean I just don't like he said I think
it was a resource issue not that they
have more resources they're going to
continue to go after people your tax
dollars at work under Biden crazy you
know we saw this happen with Brandon
straa and it was interesting the uh
quote unquote double standard there
between how he was treated and how Rays
has been treated because we saw Rays
clearly on tape whispering in a person's
ear before they break's in the front
line storming the barricades yeah
telling people we need to storm it we
need's like we need to go inside we got
to go
inside everyone's yelling fed at him
they're call him a fed and um it's it's
funny because the way the media was
responding to this very obviously
strange Silence from the uh agencies on
what he had done the media's response
say well he didn't go in the building he
didn't go in the building come on you
what kind of conspiracy theories do you
guys believing he didn't go inside okay
Brandon Str didn't either and they were
threatening him with like 20 years and
he had to plea down they were members of
The Proud boys that went away who had
not gone in the building I mean this is
like karia wasn't even in DC yeah it
doesn't matter what I think the worst
part of this it's going to be regular
Americans who were there to see Trump
speak who wandered over who are not
specifically involved in anything who
are now going to live in fear they're
going to question whether they should uh
display Trump flags at their house
they're going to question what they
should say online they're going to qu
they're going to live in paranoia
because they don't know there's already
people who fled the country I mean I
think I there are regular Americans I
know who were on law n DC coincidentally
they were there to see Trump speak who
are saying like I don't know if I should
travel internationally I'm afraid to go
to the airport it really is going to
mess with the psychology of the base of
trump some of them will dig their heels
in and say I don't care come get me but
for a lot of people they'll be afraid of
what they're risking by being open about
what they believe in my favorite thing
that I've seen so far there are a lot of
high-profile individuals as I've
mentioned who are cheering on before
January 6 happened and it may be because
they love to just be these boisterous
characters on the internet we're saying
things like yeah we're going to go to
the capital blah blah blah and then to
see these people so quick after January
6 no Trump's bad I I'm opposed to Trump
now I don't think anyone should vote for
him I'm for someone else I'm like oh are
you or are you hoping and praying that
they'll Overlook you because you've bent
the knee to the Deep State yeah I think
that's that's the real question anything
to freak uh Trump voters out and also to
panic Democrats right like every time
they put out a thing saying we've
arrested however thousand of people like
the day before the anniversary of jary 6
they said we've we've there's been over
a thousand arrests made in connection to
January 6 and that's both has it has two
effects it anger is people who feel like
that is ultimately ENT trapment day and
it makes Democrats think they're all
around me it's my neighbors if they've
already arrested a thousand people how
many people got away and it's to scare
them into voting for whoever their
candidate is even if they don't like
Biden at least he is not a a republican
because all Republicans are bad that's
the narrative that they want out there
and that's that's very that is very div
Ive I mean this is what really bothers
me about the Biden campaign right now
which is ultimately they are leveraging
fear above anything else but claiming
that that's Trump that Trump is the one
saying oh you should be afraid or we're
going to do whatever they they they
misquote him with his like I'll be a
dictator for one day all the time to
make you feel as though you being the
average you know Democrat maybe moderate
voter uh think that if you don't act now
the world is about to fall apart when
that's just fundamentally not true it's
a lie that the left is selling yeah
definitely they've been on the idea that
even from the beginning I were them
saying Oh what did they think taking
over the capital really do anything to
affect the US government are they crazy
like it turns out yes because it gives
us a reason to prosecute people who
don't agree with us and in fact a way to
hold up Trump's strongest supporters as
the Enemy of the State well before we
topic I just want to say this tomorrow
uh Ray eps's court date is tomorrow at
10: a.m. so I'm going to be outside the
courthouse see what happens so we'll see
and if I get a chance to yell at them
I'm going to call him a Fed no I that's
allegedly I don't want to get in trouble
one thing I'm actually curious about
here too with some of these people
especially what we call the magat
tourist are the application of statute
of limitations so I understanding I
think what trespassing is like like two
or three years for for statute of
limitations so some of this stuff I
don't think they would be able to go
after well that's why they had the
felony no I'm telling you that they can
go after they can't go after them as it
is and they're look you they they've
already got people on trespassing and I
made this point in
2021 that if it's it's a Simpsons joke
Homer is talking to who's he talking to
and he's like you mean if I can invite
someone I'm legally allowed that's right
and then he's like hey Flanders come
over here he's like it doesn't work if
you invite him in MH it does not work if
you invite him in you can't invite
someone somewhere and then arrest them
for it and this is what we see happening
the police opened the doors and were
Fanning people in the argument from the
left is no no they were fing the cops to
come in does not matter there's no signs
there's no barricades you can make an
argument that the people who tore the
barricades down and removed them they
committed the crimes agreed the people
who walked in afterwards seeing cops
waving people in
they thought they were being l in so the
first thing that has to happen is Sir
you need to leave your trespassing sorry
about that I'll leave then if they
refuse now you say okay you've been
warned now you're trespassing under
arrest so they shouldn't even have been
they shouldn't have even been able to go
after these people in the first place
yeah make they'll make up reasons and
we' all agree that if they just charge
these people with mis Meers and gave
them all probation nobody would even be
mad but the fact that they're throwing
the book at the magga granny people that
have cancer I mean you can tell that I
mean it's malicious what they're trying
to do let's let's uh well the granny was
from a different state everyone keeps
posting that picture of the old lady
yeah I know that was a different one but
I'm talking about the one that had
cancer that she was I think she was like
67 considering we have the uh
conspiracy-minded Alex steinen I'd like
to jump to this story from Forbes
cockpit voice recorder on Alaska
Airlines flight 1282 was he raced all
right so uh a few days ago there was an
Alaskan Airlines flight from Portland to
Ontario Canada it was no no was Ontario
California I think it was I don't know
whatever uh a section of the plane
exploded and was ripped off the plane
I'm being a little hyperbolic it deep it
pre the pressure caused it to blow off
the side of the plane couple cell phones
flew out a a bunch of people's stuff I
guess flew out the de pressurized cabin
the oxygen Mass come down the initial
report was that a window blew out then
you look at the video I don't know if
they have the video on the Forbes uh uh
website but you look at the video it was
actually apparently these 737 Max 99's
have an optional door Alaska Airline
says we don't want a door there so just
cover it up and the pressure caused to
get ripped off off the plane and go
flying and landed in someone's
backyard the cockpit voice recorder on
that plate was erased the question is
why now they'll come on and say oh it
just an accident it's an accident but I
wonder if there's actually some malfant
in that right now it's an argument that
the planes are no good following this
report we've got new information that
loose bolts are found on door plugs on
Grounded United Airlines Boeing 737 max9
jets these these door plugs are areas of
the plane they're not emergency exits
they're optional some they do you some
they don't I'm wondering how much of
this is actually the planes are bad or
are we looking at a diversity higher
problem where we have these pilots who
are incapable of doing their
jobs and so you're getting pilot error
maybe the cabin was pressurized
incorrectly causing the door to blow out
they're then yelling in the cockpit what
did you do what did you press oh no I
pressed the wrong button and then they
realize we will get in trouble and be
sued if people find out what we what we
admitted to here so they erase the
blackbox voice recorder so then it's a
oops we have no idea must it just be the
planes are no good Ashley stclair was
tweeting about a flight that landed from
new Yark New Jersey and it bounced on
the runway hard Landing nearly totaling
the plane I think the plane is disabled
it like the fuselage looks like it was
bent and cracked up and according to as
St Clair or I should say she asked asked
whether or not this was a diversity hire
who was fired and then rehired even
though they shouldn't have
been we got a pilot shortage flight
cancellations like crazy are these
Airlines hiring in large numbers and are
they hiring for diversity because uh we
know Boeing's all about it take a look
at this Global Equity diversity and
inclusion report I'm wondering if what's
really happening is the infrastructure
failur we're seeing are due to the fact
that all of these companies for the past
decade Plus have been prior izing hiring
based on ideology instead of meritocracy
mhm yeah and we have that terrible uh
Transportation secretary right P josu
has no reason to have his job I mean
this system is failing both privately
and in terms of the government it's it's
it's also interesting just as you know a
a consumer uh how much worse airline
travel has gotten since 2020 it's
terrible it's terrible flights get
canceled all the time I literally just
this past weekend I had a flight
somewhere where and the airline canceled
my flight morning of and rerouted it to
a different city they're like hey like a
city that was like an hour away I was
like they like close enough have a good
time can't just like send me somewhere
else that's not trying to fly switch so
so I had a flight from Vegas to I think
it was Dallas to
DC without telling me or asking me they
switched my ticket from a first class to
a coach last minute booking to Colorado
to DC without telling me so we show up
to the airport tickets don't work I'm
confused I'm like trying to scan the
ticket to go through security and then I
look at my email and it's like your
flight has been changed and I was like
wait what so they put me I pay for this
ticket it's expensive and I end up
sitting in the way back in a chair that
like can barely recline wow it's and
it's a triple s to the to they re not
Kidd no they didn't reimburse you you
paid for first class and you had to sit
you have to like call the airline to get
the reimbursement it's a pain but the
issue was wow none of my flights were
canceled there was a a a weather alert
in Dallas and it was delayed but that
didn't mean anything yeah my flight
would would have landed there just fine
and then I could have waited for the
delay and they said it's better if we
just put you on this flight now so you
can catch the Denver to DC and I'm like
I'll just take the delay yeah they it's
it's insane and there's no human beings
no when we showed up to the airport CU
we have an early morning flight from DC
to to come back home uh I'm sorry from
Vegas to DC there were no human beings
anywhere when I walked up to a counter I
find I a United worker I said I'm I'm I
I have a question I know it's the wrong
gate and she goes I'm not on yet and I
was like I'm sorry to bug you I just
maybe you could point me in the right
direction and then she's like nope I was
like okay dude it's great I think um a
few months ago I had a flight that was
delayed for a solid eight hours it's
like you could have just like and it was
they did they did that annoying thing
where they delay it one hour at a time
so you won't leave I was like just tell
me how long it's delayed for and I
literally I I sat there for an entire
day I was like I could have got a flight
or left or exactly they don't want you
to that's why they lie to you when when
a flight is canceled they've got 100 to
300 people now rushing to the ticket
counter to try and get new flights
they'd rather you just sit there MH and
let their you know they don't want
you're causing trouble yeah and I I
don't want to come across as xenophobic
but if I walked in and I saw two women
in the cockpit I would get off that
plane I mean seriously I mean my my my
bigger issue now seriousness is what if
you get on a plane and you see that 80%
are migrants carrying envelopes and
we've got reports Ash Ashley stclair
reported she's in possession of a ticket
that says no name given no I saw the TW
I'm not going to sit on a plane knowing
that there's a person who's not been
vetted from security and this is what's
hilarious right the left pushes for so
much documentation everywhere all the
time down to like a covid vaccine to
have on their smartphones yeah except
for when it comes to voting except for
when it comes to migration people cross
border illegally during that time were
not asked to get vac that's exactly
right but it was a requirement for legal
immigration exactly so for you as an
individual you are documented every
every moment every inch of your life is
totally documented it's just there's so
much paperwork and red tape associated
with everything you do and then when it
comes to illegal immigrants they go well
let's not call them illegal they're just
undocumented it's like wait don't you
guys hate things being undocumented why
are you okay with this being said
they're not criminals not criminals yeah
and that's rud and then Twitter did a
Comm Twitter commun not said it's quite
literally a crime to enter the country
illegally they criminals under this
section yeah Nikki Haley is man she's
evil she is she's really evil right
because she is um She's So callous about
the interests of the American people
she's okay with Waging War she literally
wanted boots on the ground in Ukraine so
she's supposedly just this totally
hawkish uh person with respect to
foreign policy and and yet she all of a
sudden just has a bleeding heart when it
comes to migration you kidding well you
know what that reminds me of like have
you seen where their celebrities now are
writing their names on the bombs that
are being used in Gaza no yeah and like
supposedly Is that real yeah some
Israeli porn stars or whatever got in
trouble because they let a porn star you
know uh right on one of the bombs
supposedly but I always think that's
very you know morbid very maob to write
your name on a bomb when you know this
is I don't care what side you're on but
that's kind of like where we're at of
the the weirdness of this all I think
that's and you know I look at everything
we're seeing with
um the the the the the the the
extreme political actions that are
happening I mean the border is just is
gone mhm Mexico wanting to uh uh well
the Border gone for them cuz Tim you and
I need a passport to leave I can't leave
the country without a passport so the
border is closed for you and I but
they're bringing people in and I just
look at all this and I'm how do we get
through this election cycle there I I
don't I don't know how come November
November 6th it's going to be November
5th we get election day does anyone
really believe that on November 6th
they're going to be like and that's it
the winner of the election is and have a
name no of course they won't be like
that I mean the thing is this is going
to be hardfought all the way and we have
known this for a long time when when
Trump was elected in 2016 you remember
do you remember all the pictures from
flights of like women in their pink hats
going to the rally like there has been
this test of like if you're the right
side you're allowed to protest but if
you're the wrong side you're allowed to
do
anything that's been there for a long
time but our tension and our anger and
the the distrust of the other side is
more heightened than ever so I think
November 6 will be a really chaotic day
and it will lead into a very chaotic
2025 that's understatement of the year I
think 2025 is going to be crazy this
next election cyle 24 is going to be
like one of those no 2025 might be super
chill you you think after it's all done
after everything's burn down we're
sitting there with like we'll be wearing
potato sacks sitting outside Chi okay
what's the new Obama movie on Netflix uh
uh you know talking about how there's
going to be a Cyber attack I think there
is going to be a Cyber attack this year
and you know what's going to be the
scary part we keep on saying all this
stuff about airplanes that's what really
gets messed up if the internet goes down
you know all of a sudden planes are
going to start crashing and then you're
really going to be like I think it's
possible I think it's possible it's not
that PL PL AR going to crash they not
going to fly when the when the system
what's a surge where you can turn off
computers I know I can't think of the
yes what if they use that and all of a
sudden air planes in the air it would be
you're not going to the whole planet
yeah but I'm just talking about a small
part of it I mean forget the whole
planet if the internet goes out planes
will emergency land and then be unable
to take off they're going to say we
can't air traffic control properly our
data streams are shut down it's an
emergency and it's a very effective way
to temporarily control uh flow of
communication imagine what would happen
for every we got 45,000 people they're
watching right now what if the internet
went down what would you watch are you
going are you really going to turn on
CNN
MSNBC there's no internet but TV still
works and they say you know turn on the
radio turn on the TV and now you're
getting the approved government
narrative well I think in this day and
age the TV and that stuff would go off
with the internet too you think they
would still be able to broadcast
absolutely yep they would just should be
using an analog whatever that yeah they
do uh they do uh um yeah I guess you are
right it's still digital air it's
digital now so you get multiple data
streams over the airwaves but they can
still send through just you you can buy
a TV turn it on and you can get the uh
the standard you know digital channels
and what what Hannah said earlier I
think that's the reason why so many
Boomers have cogn Hannah CLA what did I
say yeah no I'm just saying the reason
why these forgot half my name but sorry
I always just say Hann see Hannah Clair
what I'm saying is uh these Boomers they
have such bad cognitive dissonance
because they didn't have as many outlets
like we had they didn't have the
internet to tell them the truth about
the government that these people know
the government lies to them but they
still trust the government for some
reason we have lost all government trust
because we have the internet we know
what the hell is going on and they got
to take that away yeah and we can look
up the Tuskegee civilist we can look up
all this crazy stuff that you know is
really not the moonlanding right hey
that's what I learn I'm just saying
because of the internet that's what's
probably the biggest thorn in the
government side did you see the report I
don't know enough about it but I saw I
passively saw it so someone correct me
if I'm wrong from China that said the
moon Ling fake no they said that our
current nuclear technicians don't know
how to operate them fully because the
people who actually ran and maintained
them have retired long since retired and
the people who who who've inherited the
these jobs never had actual reason to
it's like Homer Simpson literally like
Homer Simpson 30% of our infrastructure
So when you say did we lose technology
for the moon landing the exact same
reason why they're saying our current
technicians don't know how to operate
our nuclear weapons well don't even get
me started that's apples and orig just I
do agree with that but uh yeah I mean I
don't even want to get started on the
moonlanding but yeah I'm not surprised
that these idiots can't figure out how
like look at our buildings look at all
the postmodernism all of our arure the
bridge that collapsed in Florida was
that recently I didn't no this was like
oh yeah in Miami you're talking about
The Pedestrian Bridge pedestrian bridge
yeah and it killed like two students six
people yeah I I it could be updated
since then I don't know but uh there
were memes going around saying a female
Le construction company had built it and
then the fact Checkers came out and said
did an all female Le all female
Construction Company build it see what
happens is people pointed out that this
company was promoting diversity they
were promoting female construction
workers doing they're doing ads saying
women are strong they did all this but
only a small portion of the women in
people in management were women and so
it was run it was run on by a bunch of
guys but they kept bragging about the
women who were in charge so when people
came out and said that was a female Le
company in order to try and quote
unquote debunk it or I guess you call it
a faux buunk it's not a real debunking
the media changed female Le to all
female well of course the company wasn't
all female and they said it's owned by a
man therefore they're lying fellas
here's what we got to do all right this
is my version of Dei you get your
company you get a couple positions just
for women you appoint them then when
anything goes wrong you blame them they
do you're like this is all the women's
fault there's nothing look it's girl
power and all but with with great girl
power comes great girl responsibility
there was there was a black woman who
posted on Instagram that she gets her
face put on all the corporate brochures
she never gets brought into meetings and
she's like this is how you know you're a
diversity hire yeah but I mean guys
there are gender roles some women are
not going to be plumbers like you know
what I mean I I don't know why we don't
just yeah because the patri stops them
we should encourage this I mean no they
they stop themselves like that's that's
what country a country full of who allow
women to do gross jobs is a country that
doesn't have enough enough men you'd
have to conscript them that's the
reality women are all all good when
they're like but I deserve to be CEO of
the company but as soon as you're like
please go to the oil rig they're like I
cannot no thank you that would be mean
to me I'm not equipped for that they
don't want any of the responsibilities
that men take on because like any sort
of negative or less glamorous position
women don't want that they only want to
have the uh Heralds and acolytes that
they they perceive that men are getting
and they aren't willing to pay the cont
consequences for that it's a completely
ridiculous system that they have
invented and the end result is social
collapse because what about the Disney
director said they want to make people
uncomfortable make uncomfortable imagine
if right now so here's what we have we
have women who want equality in the work
equity in the workplace they call it
they want 50-50 parity then you have men
who keep saying no no no women shouldn't
go work in the sewers and sludge around
in human waste we'll do that
job the system would collapse overnight
if men actually just all at once
completely agreed and said you know what
half the people on our team in the sewer
you know cleaning out all the sewage and
the blockages should be female then they
say well there aren't any then we won't
work I will not go down there until my
team is half male half female you have
to create like a weird Title Nine but
it's to get women to do like gross jobs
in society women will not do it so if
men one day decided I won't then Society
collapses because women will not there
will never be a circumstance where you
will mandate half the population of
women to go work on oil rigs it's just
not going to happen I mean and this is
true in domestic labor too right like we
know there's a ton of stuff that that
girls just don't want to do they're
happy to do other things and I think
that's what bothers me the most about
you know the femin feminist narr
narrative which is that it's essentially
saying men are the en enemy and they're
keeping you from doing things that would
make you happy but also we are not
willing to compromise we want all the
benefits of being female also we want
all the benefits of being male we want
none of the responsibility of either sex
yeah well that's right and I mean look
the real there's there are a lot of
things that men aren't going to do
either right there there's a lot of
domestic l a lot of stuff around the
house I mean we're really not going to
do that but there's a lot of stuff the
house that for the most part aren't
going to want to do there's a lot of
Homemaker stuff there's a lot of stay
like stay at home Dad well when we
started planting those wombs right no no
when we make uh artificial baby bags
what men are inventing a way to have
babies without women oh my gosh they
have to make one of those that yells at
you and then that's
a that's a joke women are wonderful and
I'm saying it's men doing it because the
overwhelming majority of the people
working in these fields and doing the
development and the research are males
men are are are going to create a way to
have babies without women men are going
to go their own way is that what you're
saying wait if that happened do you
think no but do you think gay men or
lesbian women would take of the world if
they could just artificially who win
yeah because that's what it's going to
be ar I'm just saying this is my point
I'm saying if they artificially make a
womb then they basically want to get rid
of heterosexual sex or they want to you
know they want to make something totally
if we create artificial wombs women lose
all political power they will lose I
don't think so all yeah
absolutely women could I think I don't
think people value women as mothers
anymore anyway like I think it's all
about like sexual objectification and
their sexual power and and and so what's
going to happen is with neuralink and
baby bags women lose all political power
I think that's true because I think you
already said that with the modern sergy
right I mean this is what Pope Francis
was talking today that he was saying it
is ultimately a form of trafficking and
it's wrong for children it's despicable
this is like his word for work quote and
I think that women I mean I think it's
two things I think basically their
voluntary participation in the porn
industry them deciding they want to be
an only fans and also their voluntary
participation in commercial surrogacy
makes it so anything they have to offer
the world can be commodified and sold
for a dollar and probably you can make
artificial technology that does it
better like a baby bag like AI porn and
so I think this is a mistake that women
are making and I think on top of that
we're severing the value of parents
right men and women both play a really
important role in their children's lives
from the beginning of time and this is
true while while women are just stating
ma male uh men still play an important
role and it's true after birth they play
yes but the denuclearization is what
they've been talking about forever yeah
and I think that's what's sad it's like
saying everything that we that makes us
unique as human beings that gives us
humanity is ultimately something you can
buy trade and sell and probably we could
make some soulless metal contraption
that could do it better well you know
what and that's not true in my opinion
you're right because when it comes to
human labor and when it comes to
production the only thing we think about
anymore is the end product that actually
ends up being produced by the process
and not what the person is transformed
into through the work and so we see this
with jobs being broken up into
components so small that a person can't
really find that much meaning in their
work because they don't actually have
any kind of vision of the larger picture
in the way that they're contributing to
it and it's a very very sad thing I was
having a conversation with someone a few
months ago and they said something very
eye openening to me um he was just
talking about how how people used to
live and how we would farm and we were
much more in tune with the seasons and
the the the days and and sort of our own
circadian rhythm was not as thrown off
by the technology we and I remember
saying like I get it and people can
romanticize that but that was
tremendously difficult that was a
tremendously difficult life to live and
those jobs were far harder than than
sitting in an office and working in an
office and he said yeah but is sitting
in an office better for you and it kind
of clicked for me I'm not I'm not saying
that we go back to an agrarian society
by any means but my point is just that
it's interesting food for thought the
jobs that we have even though they're
more productive they're actually not
good for us and people might argue oh
well these new ways of having technology
you serve roles that were traditionally
meant for human beings or things like
artificial wombs literally taking that
role which was just uniquely for women
and turning it into a technological
product that's really bad for human
beings it's really bad for human beings
no I think you're exactly right I mean I
would say 95% of corporate jobs you
really get no stake in the game so even
though you can be motivated with bonuses
if you really don't care about what
you're doing and and you don't have
anybody that's up in that company you
know I guess you know supporting you or
gassing you up or encouraging you to do
better why why would you thrive in a
system like that if you don't really
have any stake in the game exactly cuz
at some point money just isn't enough to
get you to do a certain kind of job it
really is not enough you have to
actually believe in what you're making
did you ever hear about that uh I don't
know if the story is true or not but the
professor Who challenged the students on
socialism there like a viral Tik Tock or
Instagram video where he basically said
they were arguing the merits of
socialism versus you know capitalism so
then the professor said here's what
we're going to do we're going to average
out the grades of every single person in
the class so that everyone will get an
average grade instead of the grade for
your test and then the first test they
take every everyone ends up getting like
a like a a C+ and a b or B minus and
then the people who studied really
really hard and and scored a 100 on the
test were angry because they were like I
I busted my my ass studying and I ended
up getting a bad grade because of this
the people who did nothing were super
excited because they were like I got a
great grade and didn't have to do
anything why do anything else so the
people who studied hard said I'll adjust
I don't got to work as hard because I
don't get any any reward for working as
hard so I'll invest my time somewhere
else the next test they took everyone
got a C minus now people starting to get
angry like why is our score who's not
holding their weight who's not doing the
work and then finally in the third time
everybody failed because anybody worth
doing work was like what's the point
when other people are celebrating not
doing work that's right and by the way
that's the best case scenario for
Socialism or communism what what usually
ends up happening with Communist
governments is after the first test they
round up all the people who did score
100% and say you got that by cheating
and then they execute them well no I'm
I'm antisocial ISM 100% but is
capitalism the best system I mean I I
guess it is but it needs modifications
saying well I don't know I mean I guess
some mix I mean I feel like there I'm
actually you know I don't want the
government involved at all but I do feel
like I don't know I don't know what a
system I mean yeah a capitalist economy
in my view a capitalist economy with
with some uh regulation that's what I'm
saying like imagine but that's not a
mixed economy a mixed economy like we
have is we half your money goes to taxes
and half your money goes in your pocket
right yeah we need a flat tax I mean
that's one thing I mean our just and I'm
sure you're in a totally different tax
bracket Tim you must be sick you pay I
mean I'm sick now cuz I'm in a higher
bracket than I've been in the past few
years but it's not just bracket I think
something like 65 or 70% of all my
income is taxes or some I mean I pay
over 40% I paid over 40% I think it was
like 40 so here here's here's the trick
they don't tell you about um higher
taxes means spending more money yeah I
know oh yeah if if you're somebody let's
say you make a million bucks a year and
uh you look at your taxes and like Joe
Biden's raising your taxes if I let's
say I have $100,000 in profit and I
don't spend it y I write a check to the
government for 40 Grand how about just
spend the 100 Grand and retain the asset
value but it's got to be specific things
like I'll just say screw it instead of
having the money sitting around I'll
just hire a guy at 100,000 to paint
because at least the paintings are
assets held by the company that retain
value and then I don't lose the money to
the government well have you seen the
Tik to that goes viral where it's a it's
like Bill 179 where if you buy a G wagon
because it weighs over 6,000 pounds you
can write it off for a company and
that's why so many people buy the G
wagon it's gotten you know hundreds of
millions of hits you need to look it up
because and there's a few cars that um
hit that tax certain but they they
control they they can control the speed
and expansion of the economy that's the
point of the Federal Reserve it's the
point of their tax policy modern
monetary theory is not you're taxed so
that the government gets money no the
the the government just creates money on
the upon the Agents of debt taking money
from you is just to control the speed at
which people are hiring and firing
people well and that's the thing right
so as somebody who does uh run their own
business when you get your paycheck they
don't deduct anything from it right
you're colting money from from clients
or AdSense or or sponsors and then you
have to cut that check yourself
eventually quarterly or once a year feel
it you really feel it and the thing is
you feel it and you go if I really
believed in what the government was
doing this wouldn't hurt so bad like if
I really even though this is way too
much money and I don't think anyone
should be taxed uh at this level and I I
I really think there's something wrong
with govern I believe
thought they were doing good things with
it it wouldn't hurt nearly as bad it
really I got to be honest um based on
how much money I've already been taxed I
as a single individual I'm probably
responsible for like I don't know at
least one wedding that's been blown up
yeah more than one but isn't this what
they say about uh Scandinavian countries
that have high social security Nets is
that they actually say like like people
in Denmark are like no no we're we're
cool to pay these taxes because
ultimately we like the benefits that we
reap from them I mean it's one of the
reasons that they are so disturbed by m
immigration which is that they realize
there are people coming in who don't pay
into the system I mean there are people
that have extremely high tax rates they
have a large you know social safety net
from the government and it's okay it's
just not true in America because our
system doesn't doesn't have either one
of the benefits right it's not fair it's
not equal we we don't have the the
benefits that people might want and we
don't have the low but we have the high
taxes so what are we ultimately doing
here I think I think the challenge one
of the big challenges is uh stupid
people versus smart people
and evil people as well so like when I
look at the Democrats what do I tend to
see there are very few but very smart
evil people and a whole lot of really
really dumb people when I look at the
quote unquote right I don't mean just
the Democrats because the right is a
collection of Libertarians conservatives
I see a lot of people who are moderately
intelligent and a handful of people who
are very very stupid because every
because stupid people exist everywhere
but if you have a handful of people who
if you have commentators on the right
who are like I'll try to be honest and
believe in Liberty which means you got
to make your own choices the stupid
people end up with a moderately better
understanding of the world and their
freedoms whereas the Democrats believe
in insane things that make no sense I'll
give you an example Marian Williamson
tweeted uh Kyle Griffin of NBC news said
Elise stonic will not commit to
certifying the 2024 election Marian
Williams said Mar Marian Williamson said
this is insane let's break it down what
did Alise stanic actually say she
said if it's constitutional yes I'll
certify it which is quite literally a
commitment to certify the election yep
because if it wasn't then the purpose of
her job is to not certify it Marion
Williamson gets this fake story from
Kyle Griffin of NBC he's lying
misleading through a mission to trick
people like Marian Williamson who
believes it Marian Williamson is the I
suppose you'd call this the the the
ignorance of evil we we all here like
Maran because she's a nice person she's
a good moral person but she believes
wrong things and we believe that if we
actually just talked to her she'd
understand and she did when she came on
the show when we showed her the the
creepy books and everything she like
these things are wrong and we're like we
because you're a good person we know you
are but if she believes NBC she lives in
a world of
lies and so this is what we end up
dealing with in the culture War the left
is a whole bunch of really really dumb
people and so when it comes to trying to
solve our problems you have disgusting
evil people like Oliver Darcy like Kyle
Griffin and then you're like how do we
actually make the world a better place
when you have figurative or literal
demons lying to stupid people to trick
them into harming themselves well I mean
everything you hear on the mainstream
media from NBC is is fake and I think
people are starting to realize that
though Tim don't you think or or do you
think people are still kind of under
that brainwash I think I think a lot of
people are starting to wake up to it you
know and I think programs like this and
the shift in how we consume media is
helping change this podcasts are taking
over but this is this is the Big
Challenge we have right now there would
be no question of the 2024 election if
we didn't have NBC News and CNN and
MSNBC lying about everything yeah these
people are they're evil it's it's not a
question it's malicious evil you and I
were actually talking about this earlier
today at lunch it would basically be
like if a health inspector was asked
will you pass this restaurant they're
like I mean if healthy it's someone
comes to you and says
will will building inspector will you
commit to certifying my building that I
will build next
year like what you no I have to check to
see built right if it's up to code then
yeah and then I report building
inspector will not commit to certifying
the building it's like well you didn't
build it yet he'd actually be really bad
at his job if he did commit to
certifying it before seeing it yep
that's where we're currently at
Democrats are shocked first at a fake
story yo NBC News is the most captured
institution in this in this in the in
the media apparatus you think worse than
CNN absolutely wow NBC ABC Disney yes no
question yo the the NBC News team like
Ben Collins they they fabricate the most
egregious things imaginable as a
statement of fact they put out
fabricated narratives come at me bro
statement of fact they do it and I
believe they do it intentionally I'd
love to get Discovery on these guys and
it's remarkable they give these people
awards look Alisa toonic was asked would
she certify the election yeah if it's
constitutional of
course yes she said yes and what does
NBC news report she will not commit to
certifying the election that's a lie
that's just fake they they fabricated
that and then Marion Williamson believes
it and she's running for president and
polling in some in in in some of the
latest polls at
13% it's amazing isn't it the same media
company I mean the only reason I would
say ABC is you know you saw that video
where they were trying to bring up
Jeffrey Epstein years ago and then they
killed that story but whether whether or
not I think NBC news as a whole is like
a fake news machine well you know Fox
News you know I think Tucker Carlson ran
into this like you think oh this is a
conservative Media company but there's a
lot of liberal people that work in there
that are just in Hollywood that are in
Show Business I mean like do you trust
any of the political biases of any of
these networks I mean I I really don't
like I don't
yeah I don't think new NBC News is is is
is is a king of the castle man yeah CU I
guess the biggest I mean look NBC news
they did this thing once where some
activists wrote a fake story about me
NBC news then cited it in an article
then a bunch of entertainment Outlets
quoted NBC News NBC news then removed
the citation creating a dead Loop of a
bunch of entertainment news
organizations citing each other with no
actual source for where the claim came
from the original was like a blog or
something is that they decided it was a
Blog just something yeah it was some
guy's blog and then when I contacted one
of these entertainment out saying hey
this is a fake story I want to
correction they say take it up with
insert other Outlet because they're the
ones who are making the claim then I
went to that so Outlet one says talk to
outlet two I go to outlet two and they
go hey look we're sting Outlet three I
went to outlet three and goes hey look
we're sting Outlet one so if it was just
two outlets and one and they're claiming
each other I could point out you guys
are just citing each other with three
Outlets they said I don't know what NBC
is doing we're citing this this website
and then I said yeah but that that
website setting NBC and they were like I
don't know anything about that take it
up with them you can't sue me for
defamation because it's already in the
public sphere and we believe that what's
reported by insert Outlet is correct so
none of them will take it down that's
NBC News these people are despicable
evil they know they're lying and they
love playing this game where they go
online and they go Trump supporters are
lying and then when you stare them in
the face and talk to them and say Here's
the actual proof and report that you
lied they smile and say good luck evil
people man I don't disagree and then I
see that on Wikipedia too where like the
somebody have some weird Wikipedia thing
and it'll be cited to some random blog
you're like how does that well this is a
they call it uh it was XKCD comic called
it
pyogenesis where they say uh the example
actually let me let me pull up Cog
Genesis it's really really great you you
you'll understand how uh we are in a
very serious uh check it out where
citations come from Cog Genesis step one
through a convoluted process a user's
brain generates facts these are typed
into Wikipedia The Scroll lock key was
designed by Future Energy Secretary
Steven Chu in a college project somebody
makes something up a rushed writer
checks Wikipedia for a summary of their
subject US Energy Secretary Steven Chu
Kama Nobel Prize winner and creator of
the ubiquitous scroll lock key testified
before Congress today surprised readers
check Wikipedia see the claim and flag
it for review a passing editor finds the
piece and adds it as a citation Google
is your friend people now that other
writers have a real Source they repeat
the fact the simple version is it's not
just about Wikipedia someone will
fabricate a story in the corporate press
on purpose remember that big Scandal has
been a bunch that one guy who worked for
build in Germany was just making a bunch
of things up and they caught him someone
will make up something
or a better example Kyle Griffin will
tweet at least aonic will not commit to
certifying the election that's that's a
fake story that's M fabricated by Kyle
Griffin he he made that up someone like
Marion Williamson will see this and say
this is insane and then I don't know uh
insert CNN or any other news Outlet will
write a story saying Marian Williamson
slams Elis toonic saying it is insane
that she refuses to certify the election
they will then say NBC News reported at
least a phonic says she will not certify
the 2024 election MH something that
never happened then every other
corporate Outlet will just rewrite what
CNN wrote citing CN CN if CNN figures
out the mistake and they get rid of it
all these news outlets will just insert
a different source and create another
loop of of fake news this happens in
Academia too I can't remember who coined
this term but they refer to it as ideal
laundering yep yeah makes sense you just
literally say anything and then you get
some citations a couple people cite you
and then people cite them and and the
language is manipulative right so if I
said you know if you describe Sheamus as
you know a thought criminal and then I
said Sheamus who has been described in
the past as a thought criminal I am
correct you have described him as a
thought criminal but is he actually or
has he just been described that way and
it becomes this like Echo chamber of
like worsening criticism Sheamus who
obviously is the worst ever but it's
this is the game they play because the
corporate press loves to add descriptors
to people for no reason that's right so
uh yeah they'll say like Donald Trump
comma who who like Julian Assange he'll
be in the news because uh he released a
document they'll say Julian Assange
comma accused rapist and blah exactly
not relevant to the story but but not
true either the issue is what'll happen
is how many people have accused Bill
Clinton of being a pedophile everybody I
mean Millions right yeah so if you were
to report that in a story Bill Clinton
comma an accused pedophile comma is that
a false statement to effect absolutely
not he's been accused by a lot of people
of being a pedophile and this is the
this is the game that the corporate
press plays well speaking of pedophile
and I wanted to uh you know you aside
from ped little I do because you know a
lot of people want to give Donald Trump
credit for saying the fake news but the
first person to say fake news and Tim
I'll kind of end on this conspiracy my
favorite conspiracy of them all you
asked me what my top one is I believe
Michael Jackson was innocent only
because he was uh you know he was the
first person to say that the news is
fake and then on top of that he was
investigated by the FBI for 19 years and
then Wade Robinson and James safechuck
the two guys that made the documentary
leaving Neverland Wade Robinson actually
testified on his behalf twice in front
of California's top prosecutor and said
that nothing happened and then James
safe Chuck said that he was um you know
sexually assaulted inside the train
station in the year that he said it the
uh architect hadn't even drawn the plans
so my point is yeah there's a lot of
weird inconsistencies with the Michael
Jackson situation y look at the look at
the he's the first one to say fake news
so the it is it is very obvious that the
left is willing to lie about anything if
it advances their goals the Brett
Kavanaugh story is the perfect example
of waves of people coming out with the
most ridiculous Fabrications what was
Amy Comey bear what do they what do they
say she did that she was like a white
nationalist or something they said they
literally was excuse me an adopted child
who was black and they were trying yeah
and they were like trying to say she was
racist because I was like what we're
going to go to Super Chat so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel head over to cast brew.com and
by Alex Stein's Prime Time grind two
times caffeine drink responsibly it does
have two times the caffeine in it so uh
you got to be really careful with that
but uh uh you can also go to
timcast.net become a member because the
uncensored show will be coming up in
about 20 minutes and as a member you get
access to our Discord server to hang out
with like-minded individuals there's
pre-shows there's after shows a Vibrant
Community of people talking debating and
uh building stuff but more importantly
this show is made possible in part by
viewers like you if you like the stuff
we do tomorrow we will be flying on a
Jet right after the show ends we have to
run immediately out the door to an
airport get on a jet fly to Iowa for the
vet ramaswami Town Hall if you you
support our endeavors in doing these
things we're not making a profit off of
doing this in fact we're going to be
losing a lot of money these are very
very expensive it's I I'll just tell you
guys the whole thing's probably going to
cost a hundred plus
thousand and we can afford to do it
because you guys are members we are not
profiting off of it directly in the
sense that we're not going to from the
event and from ticket sales have a
surplus of cash but I do believe it is
healthy for the business that we do
things like this because it it creates
value granted it is only possible to
invest in these kinds of things if guys
become members at
timcast.net the neo-nazis because they
should be condemned totally the example
is that video which we all know exists
it will emerge in a similar scenario two
videos will appear on the internet one
in which it says C-SPAN Donald Trump
speaks and he says and I'm not talking
about the white nationalists or Theodis
because they should be condemed totally
the second video will be him saying
because some of them should be condemed
totally that tiny alteration from they
to some of them or they to some because
some should be condemned totally because
they should be all they have to do is
change one word what'll happen then is
Democrats will go nuts some should be
condemned I can't believe you would say
this Trump will then come out I said no
I said they should be condemned Trump
supporters will be like here's the video
Democrats and Trump supporters will both
claim both videos are the original
videos Good
Luck it's if a video comes out of trump
on Epstein Island doesn't matter Trump
supporters won't buy it they'll say
you're lying a video comes out that is
slightly altered in a tiny way every
one's confused and that's easier to
change super easy yeah terrifying yeah
all right Shane H Wilder says the pimp
on a blimp is here hide your kids hide
your wife facts hide them yeah would you
ever do a cover of that song what hide
your wife hide your kid what was that
guy name Anton gosh legendary guy but it
was uh all thanks to Schmo Yoho I
believe right who made the autotuned
version of that that went super viral
yeah that that guy was just giving an
interview and he said it and then it was
I think it was shimoo I'm not sure who
made the auto turn autotune version when
that went viral where's the
pimp that's what I want to know well you
know it's funny you say that because
honestly that's kind of what I became
most popular for is doing stupid raps I
guess the video that like the first
video that ever got that got 20 million
views with me doing a stupid cringy
vaccinate my body vaccinate me at the
party yeah so just funny how rapping
there's something about that how just
it's powerful culture abduction says
today is my birthday I'd love if Tim
sounded like Nancy and Ian screamed like
a chicken and Phil do his Infamous yell
and Alex just be yourself well Phil and
Ian aren't here but I will say this
happy birthday to you and Donald Trump
is the worst president it's country has
ever had Tim I have to say too your
Trump that you just did a second ago I
mean you're you're getting really spot
on I think that's from all the practice
that was very accurate I think it's
actually one of my worst no I was just
blown away by it I'm not even trying to
kiss your butt I I I've heard you do it
a lot but I feel like you were even more
into it the role that time when you just
did it again the the Nancy voice that I
do is an intentionally disgusting
sounding voice cuz I'm not actually
trying to impersonate her that's why it
sounds a you're impersonating a
character of her kind of I'm just trying
to make it sound disgusting as possible
and just like as strained and struggling
as possible because it's meant to be an
insult whereas Trump I'm just trying to
impersonate Trump your Trump's accur but
that but that's rally Trump like I can't
do regular Trump like when Trump's just
sitting there and he's like talking
calmly it's really hard to like get that
but he's talking like this you know and
he's doing the thing and and and he like
size those those rally voices are easy
to
get kov says did you guys see the debate
with Destiny and Alex Jones I thought
Alex was going to unleash his inner
gorilla and Maul Destiny's face uh I
just couldn't even with that debate I
didn't know what they were debating all
it was was like I'm sorry guys I can't
do it did you guys did you the cren
Stein sitting right there maybe want to
PUK but they weren't arguing anything
well but did you see Alex Jones was kind
of slapping Destiny's back and he's like
don't touch me bro that was the best
part of the whole no no you are no you
are no you are that's why I'm like
they're not they're not arguing they're
not debating what would happen is uh and
there were some good points in there but
I will point out my the issue I had with
it was Alex Jones says you you know uh 1
2 3 ABC and then Destiny would go XYZ
jkl and I'm like they're literally not
arguing Alex Jones would say something
like I think this about the capital and
then Destiny would bring up a total non
seor and be like I'll give you an
example uh or I guess what I mean to say
is with the debate I'm expecting someone
to be like Donald Trump should not be
president the 14th amendment should
remove him that's my position what is
your position I believe that he should
not be removed now we will argue they
were arguing over whether or not they
believed certain news articles were true
or fake and I'm like that it's
meaningless you agree with CNN you don't
agree with CNN what is the point of this
so I just I'm just like I don't even
know man I I I can't handle that kind of
stuff that's just me yeah but you really
I mean Destiny you saw what happened his
wife he's going through a divorce he's
really going through a tough time right
now that's rough think should have sign
up for the debate if I'm going to debate
someone like Destiny then we can
certainly argue if he's got something
wrong and I can pull up a source to
prove him wrong and if he Pro and when
he was here we were talking about um
transgender youth he told me that he
believed my numbers were incorrect we
double checked my numbers were incorrect
I'm totally fine with that if Destiny
says I believe that uh Donald Trump is
the is the reason for why the people
were there on January 6 which what he
said my response is if that is true do
you believe that not being present and
not orchestrating an event makes you
legally culpable instead what we got
is people yelling at each other and
whenever someone would would make a
point the other person would change the
subject and so I was just like I I don't
even know what's going well internet
debates I don't know if it ever actually
changes anybody's Minds right it's just
kind of like you know what I I if people
are totally I think you're right that
there's a huge huge faction of people
aren't going to CH like change their
mind some people just love Alex Jones
and are tuned in to see him some people
just love Destiny are tuned in to see
him I heard somebody want a chicken
scream for their birthday oh my go
microphone
on
happy birthday Ian's been here the whole
time I had it hard I thought we were
getting swatted for a second that was
incredible I love you Alex love you Ian
thank you for the screen we love it love
you big guy okay so uh who I was I think
some undecided people will change their
mind people aren't fans of either
culture abductions you got your birthday
wish Ian came and made it and and and it
came true that was like top 10 moment
for the show yeah that was great my
pulse shot up when the door behind I was
hoping was hoping we're going to get
swatted so we get like a views but
that's just where my head is so we got
uh uh ker here says won a good bit of
money in poker yesterday got to use some
support to support the crew about to
order more Cas Brew right now as well
keep up the good work and much love from
North Carolina I have good
news uh the new timcast studio which is
this is this is getting wild ladies and
gentlemen it's 50 plus acres it's got a
40 foot tall 50 plus acres 40 foot tall
building three structures three total
standing structures a a total of maybe
like in terms of building structure
let's say I don't know we're probably
looking at like 12 13,000 square feet of
internal structure actually more than
that I'm sorry it's uh maybe like 15 uh
it is officially
done formal final inspections are all
done the crew that we've got working on
it has set a timeline for the C Brew
Coffee House by mid April it should be
completely done and it's taken a really
really long time because it is really
difficult especially in the co era to
get contractors that are doing things
right and uh the problem is every time
one contractor falls off it like resets
the permitting and caus a bunch of
problems but this new crew that's
working with us is really really great
and it's doing really well uh that being
said congratulations on your winning a
good amount of money in poker yesterday
I too won a good amount of money in
poker yesterday the first thing I'll say
is I was playing at MGM National Harbor
buying for 500 within about an hour or
two I'm at 15 pocket Queens do dude I
know nobody cares about poker but for
those that do this is this is this was a
once in A- lifetime moment I got queen
of diamond Queen of
Hearts it's like a guy the so a guy in
seat one small blind uh uh I don't know
if he's small blind anyway he he raised
it to 15 we get two calls it comes to me
on the button so I raise to 50
considering the amount of players that
are in the guy uh uh first the guy who
raises calls the next guy calls the next
guy raises I Jam instantly cuz I got
pocket Queen oh no no I'm sorry I'm
sorry I call and the FL he no he doesn't
raise they they all call around my 50
and the Flop comes like two hearts and
it's like it's it's it's like two hearts
to the
board I'm looking now it's like Jack
nine something I've got an over pair
with the Queen of Hearts so I'm blocking
the flush with the over pair we get a
bet of 100 100 I'm like maybe they got
sets but I got the over pair I shove all
in 500 bucks four uh four players call
three three players call so it's me the
the turn comes a heart and now I'm
worried I'm dead to the flush the river
comes a heart so I make the Queen of
Hearts flush and then the guy in the
first heat flips over Ace eight of
Hearts the other guy mucks his cards the
guy to my right flips over King 10 of
hearts for three made flushes all in the
hand I lost all my money it was awesome
but then uh uh I I went to dinner came
back bought in for a uh with 194 and
chips that Alison had left over I uh got
in for 2 hours 194
in 1400 out flat 1400 out you got you
you know I'm telling you Tim you got to
have on Vegas Matt he's probably the
number one professional poker player on
YouTube I mean I mean a a professional
slot player professional Gambler and
he's huge his Channel's blowing up on
YouTube but you'd love this guy be fun I
think the important thing people
understand about poker is it's not
gambling when you go to like a big
tourist spot it was wild like this one
guy kept calling me stupid because of
the way I was playing but I was like I'm
just doing math I'm like how many well I
have to say this Tim I've been to the
casino Tim some people are scared to
death of Tim when they see him walk in
because you know you know he's got a
little bit of money and some people are
like oh I want to go play next to Tim
because you play so wild if if it's a
400 Max buyin at MGM it's 500 sure I'm
not scared of throwing money but I'm not
I'm not just throwing money and bullying
the table I won a little bit you bully
the table a little bit when we play yes
it it's people are like why are you
betting I'm like bro we're playing poker
there's there's three so I I bet 50
bucks and uh this guy the guy to my
right gets all angry and he's like why
would you bet $ and I'm like I bet pot I
was like I've got top pair top kicker
there's three players in I bet pot I
think it's fairly standard play to bet
$50 but Tim you know when you sit at
that TBL half the people at that table
100 bucks is a lot of money to them a
lot don't buy in at the minimum $100 to
play to to play poker at a table with a
$500 Max no I know I'm Hey listen and
you go to gamble you go for the stakes
you go to play a little bit clearly one
of the regs he's like as a standard bet
like he he a standard C bet like why why
I'm like I'm bro I didn't I didn't Jam
$500 all in on a garbage pair yeah but
to them 50 bucks is like 500 bucks you
know no dude there are people at the
table who already have who already have
double triple their buyings like some
some guys complaining because they don't
understand like the basic math they
think if I got Ace King I can make a bet
if I don't I fold I went up against a
guy it was it was monotone board clubs
and the guy at Ace King with the Ace of
clubs and he did not semi Bluff me okay
that I think he made a big mistake I had
I had a a uh I had an overpair and uh I
think I think I like tens and the board
was like nine high with three clubs and
so I'm thinking like I don't think he's
got the maid flush I'm going to make the
BET and then the guy instantly folds his
hand I'm like you you had the ace you
could have at least tried to see the
turn or whatever but I I was he was
actually uh uh I checked he's in
position he checks back I'm like bro
make a c bet make you have the a yeah
but they don't want to raise you because
they know you're going to call that's
that's not true dude I am not playing
and blindly calling every I know that
I'm just saying you are a wealthy young
man that's pretty good post this guy
doesn't know who I am he's got Ace King
with the Ace of clubs for the flush he
makes a big bet he bets pot I fold
instantly but nobody plays that way and
that's fine I guess but I'm saying if
you if you know how to play even a
little bit well you go to you go to
these tourist spots and play low stakes
and like you can win granted the rake is
brutal but let's not stop let's stop
stop talking about poker and read super
chats
again all right let's grab uh let's grab
some more Melanie says there is no Trump
tape they would have released it a long
time ago I completely agree I completely
agree Doc Holiday says are you watching
Luke this is responsible covering
instead of omission by
TDS why is that what Luke
did yeah I don't know I I mean the video
I did earlier before I knew it was
recanted I basically said if Trump's
accused investigate him but considering
we've got one witness saying Trump was
never there one witness saying he was
it's moot it's it's it's the score is
it's negative 1 to1 I don't know what to
make of that but with Bill Clinton
you've got accusations that he likes him
young he was trying to shut down down
the story and there's tapes of him and
ain't nobody saying he wasn't there so
it's stacked against Bill
Clinton all right let's grab some more
Super chats Matt tastic says 136 million
registered voters 81 million for Joe 74
million for Trump it's a total of 155
million votes but Matts I Googled the
census report and it said 168 million
voters ra registered voters now if
that's the case it's still just massive
voter turnout but uh believe I mean I
don't to tell you I mean perhaps the
sentence is lying or whatever I don't
know but I believe that number is
incorrect be Lane says the hotel
building I work in blew up today Fort
Worth I think the societal deterioration
and lack of blue collar workers is
becoming so dangerous people just can't
do their jobs properly anymore did you
see that explosion that was a gas
explosion I mean I'm telling you guys
you got to get out of the cities and get
chickens I mean you have a point I mean
the airplanes are falling apart
buildings are blowing up I mean there's
a lot
I have kind of losing faith in society
but I mean I don't know I don't know
what the solution is to run away I guess
I think so I think you to start learning
how to survive and I recommend
downloading several survival guides more
than one to your phone um think about
how you will charge your phone and the
event the power goes out what Eric
Prince told us this is amazing uh so the
culture War podcast has been doing
massively well it's it was great with
Alex Rosen I want to give a shout out I
like that episode with Alex Rosen he's
doing great work Predator post
oh yeah right on and uh the episode we
had with you I think is is our our yeah
that was a good one though one of our
biggest our biggest on tenant tenant
media where you can find the show but we
we we had a clip with Eric Prince
300,000 hits where he's talking about
what happens in a civil war he basically
said everybody he knows who's been in
countries where it's where it's the
government's Fallen apart overnight
there's no gradual you know turmoil it's
just instantly you wake up one day the
power's off there's no internet there's
no
electricity so if we are headed towards
a very dark path my recommendation for
everybody is just figure out where
you're getting electricity from let me
tell you we've got methods here at
timcast of generating electricity which
I will not disclose we have very obvious
ones I have a van that I built following
that Joe rugan podcast when I told him
I'm going to build a van a bugout van
it's got solar panels on the roof and a
very powerful uh electrical system based
on how much power it can generate it can
run a video game system and a computer
indefinitely the amount of power that it
consumes throughout the night is
completely replenished throughout the
day even in winter it's a it's a very
very powerful solar system we have these
little these little little batteries
they're called Delta you can find and
you can purchase with them solar panels
and we've run tests on them already
they're unfold the solar panels and plug
them in it charges up we laid out I
think like 12 panels and it was like
total charge time for the battery is
like 2 hours this battery can power a a
portable air conditioner for about 45
minutes that's pretty nuts air
conditioners take a ton of juice it can
it can run we use these batteries as
emergency backups for the power goes out
this studio will operate just fine
should the power go go out off these
batteries after several hours we don't
we don't we don't even worry about the
batteries we just plug them back in you
know so if it hits the fan figure out
where you're getting juice from and if
you're not getting any you better have
chickens no seriously a generator would
be really good either a solar powered
one or you know real yeah that's what
I'm saying you ain't getting gas yeah I
know so that would be really good also
get one of those filtering straws I
forget what they're called but you can
kind of like turn it
we got a bunch of those yes I know those
are really got a ton of them and uh
surprisingly though you know MREs you
got to store them properly I would
recommend training guns and ammunition
properly uh stored and uh properly
trained and all that good stuff Let's uh
let's read some more Super chats poly p
says where is Ian is he okay y'all Y
y'all figured that one out
already rule of the star says the potato
guy looks Ill get him a steak hope this
is enough to get the whole class of
steak too we will have a delicious steak
I'm really excited for Wednesday it's is
a very difficult thing to pull off we
have our own uh uh little unit in an
office building where we'll be setting
up the show uh only 50 tickets for each
event the live caucus will have rotating
uh groups coming in wait there's only 50
cuz everybody on V staff I was there
they're like oh we can't get tickets we
can't get tickets because I was saying
oh Tim's going to be here that's why
there's only 50 tickets oh they I I I
don't know who bought them all I know is
the first tickets only went out to
members and I'm pretty sure only members
got them yeah yeah I thought there'd be
more tickets oh wow only 50 yeah cuz
everybody that was there is like I want
to go I can't get tickets I was like uh
sorry so the first event we did 50 bucks
we're not making money off the tickets
it's mostly just about screening and
that's why it went to Members First and
it was 50 bucks because we also have to
have security guards you know V
everybody however that being said if
like some activist showed up and started
yelling at V I'm sure V would handle it
masterfully CU he does he does and it is
it is what it is that would be the most
entertaining outcome El the second event
we did 150 because we actually have more
people coming in including VI and others
and
this time it's like this one's a bigger
extended Show event but here's the most
important thing we we released it only
to Members First and then we were going
to open it up afterwards but I think it
sold out instantly for especially for
people who are in the area who already
going to the first event probably going
to go the second one but yo 50 people in
this room basically means we're all just
going to be hanging out yeah this is not
like you're in an auditorium it's
literally a single room office building
like where we are is a unit in an office
building and so you'll literally be like
I'm going to be at a table you're going
to be at a chair and you're going to be
sitting 20t away watching the show so we
definitely have to vet the you know but
it's going to be the show wraps
everyone's going to be hanging out
having you know coffee and whatever and
hanging out so it's going to be super
exciting all right bad Buddha says
Shameless chat rat love for Alex Stein
watching Prime Time with Alex Stein
every Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday
from 4 to 500 p.m. Pacific is the
highlight of my week keep fighting the
good fight thank you bad Buddhist he is
one of the most loyal chat rats wow
thank you for for that super chat right
on three if byet says y'all Tommy Shelby
from pey blinders give us the answer to
the gender pay Gap increase the pay of
the women and reduce the equivalent pay
for men at Christmas during inflation no
more noise the enemy isn't coming
they're always here but I I don't I
don't I don't understand how that solves
the problem get it well and the gender
wage Gap is not real in only fans women
make a lot more money than men so I
think in entertainment women make more
so uh there are more women getting paid
higher rates than men in entertainment
on average the pay get favor women but
the most famous men typically make more
than the most famous the leading top
actors yeah all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
YouTube channel share the show I'm
thinking about trying we're trying to
figure out how to do a commercial for
timcast we've never done any like real
commercial for it we've done Billboards
and stuff which kind of like I don't
know if they work I guess it should
literally just be Ian coming into to
scream the chicken sound but I mean in
terms of a serious we're going to spend
money that's not going to do anything
for us I just think it would be really
good for us I think it'll get people
watching it'll be funny watch because
quite literally we're trying to reach
out to a new person who's never seen the
show before and explain to them what
they get when they watch the show and
Ian screaming like a chicken is only
sometimes yeah no it needs to be like
you like occupy and then you on Rogan
and then you on this why not like
timcast because that's not what timcast
IRL is it could be it is you it be me
it's wait you don't think this show is
you I would say yeah but like no half
the people I would say 90% of people
watch the show have never seen me do
field reporting from Occupy Wall Street
yeah but that's kind of what made you
Tim pool right but that's not material
to what this show is it would just be
cool I like that you know the time I was
thinking maybe what we do is like every
Monday morning I'll just record a quick
video where I announce our guests oh
yeah and we normally don't like to
announce guests because then they cancel
on us and we lose them but I'm like
maybe it doesn't matter Maybe by
announcing them they won't cancel
because we'll run an ad on YouTube where
it's like this week Monday we've got you
know Alex Stein Tuesday we've got so and
so Wednesday we have this person Friday
that person blah blah blah maybe we'll
do that anyway uh follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast subscribe to Tim become a
member at
timcast.net
thank you we can get your coffee now too
yeah oh yeah guys get the prime time
grind and remember the proceeds are
going to go help out a lot of sick and
stray cats so that's what matters the
most want to help out these felines I
want to shout out my best bud Luke uh
and I also want to shout out I have a
YouTube channel uh it's called Freedom
Tunes uh and we do animated cartoons
about politics at least once a week we
have been releasing some videos lately
that I think are super super funny so if
you guys want to go there and check it
out just know that it's the the cartoon
channel run by Luke's best bud best bud
ever in life best bud ever prob yeah I'd
say so wow we I mean is are any of his
other best buds on a shirt with him
that's true uh I'm Hannah CL Rim I'm a
writer for cnr.com that's scanner newws
you can see our work on uh Twitter and
Instagram at timcast news if you want to
follow me personally I'm on uh Twitter
at hcbo and I'm on instagrram at
handler. guys thanks so much the the
best part of uh the shirt is that on the
shirt Luke is wearing the shirt shirt
who is who's wearing the shirt wearing
the shirt as well that's just my best
that's how deep they're my best Luke
really thinks ahe you know I appreciate
that about him yeah anyway
Serge oh wow this has been a fun Saga to
watch unfold uh yeah I'm surge.com I'm
ready for the after show thanks for
coming Alex always a pleasure I'm a chat
rat
too I hang out I watch uh yeah anyways
we'll see you all over at timcast.net